Okay, da bin ich.
Aber so wie es aussieht, ihr noch nicht.
Doch, das Small Access Point, der Name passt heute aber richtig gut, Alter.
Small Access Point.
Warte mal, ich glaube, ich habe die Musik ein bisschen laut.
Ah, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Teams hat wieder am Sound rumgestellt.
Keck, wait.
Warum macht Teams so Dinger?
Anzeige ist mehrfach.
In Bearbeitung schon.
So, passt.
Benni, dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Subscriptions.
Rock Champ.
Moin, ByteStrikes.
Ah, anscheinend ist heute WeepsIn angesagt.
Ich sehe schon.
Ich habe heute Morgen schon...
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle.
Ich überlege gerade.
Ich glaube, 8 Kilometer.
Oder so.
Berg rauf, berg runter gelaufen.
Ich bin irgendwie ein bisschen im Arsch noch.
Aber das macht nichts.
Und außerdem.
Vor allem, weil ich...
gerade richtig...
Pippo Fett gefuttert habe.
Aber ich muss jetzt streamen.
Ich habe gestern auch gesagt,
heute gucken wir uns die neuen Access Points an.
Dann gucken wir uns heute auch die neuen Access Points an.
Und wenn wir uns die angeguckt haben,
dann kann ich über die nächsten Tage
Unify bei mir rausschmeißen.
Dann bin ich ehrlich gesagt ganz froh drüber.
Pausierungschamp.
Moin, Rinax.
Rinax?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das genau ausspricht.
Aber du weißt,
du weißt ja, wer gemeint ist.
Ich muss mal kurz Update in meiner VM machen.
Aha, Bing Image of the Days.
Eine Windmühle.
Okay.
Gut zu wissen.
WiFi 6.
Nein, kein WiFi 6.
Weil mit WiFi 6 über 1000 Euro.
Und da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Lul.
Erstmal Update machen.
Warum kein Fan von Unify?
Weil es mir auf den Sack geht.
Wow.
Alter, was ist mit den Unify Updates
bitte schön los gerade?
OKS?
Hat Manjaro wieder abgefahren?
Fuckt mit ihren Keys.
Habe ich auch schon mal hingekriegt.
Wobei scheinen OK zu sein.
Na gut, updaten wir mal.
Womit virtualisierst du das ist vor allem bei Workstation?
Kann ich auch jedem nur empfehlen.
Vor allem bei Workstation ist wirklich richtig.
Poggi.
Also richtig nice.
Mir persönlich gefällt das deutlich besser.
Als Beispielsweise VirtualBox, zumindest für Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Im Server-Bereich kann man sich drüber streiten, was man da nimmt.
Ja, da hat sicherlich auch sowas wie KVM oder meinetwegen noch Xen,
Zutrix, sonstiges Gedöns.
Sag mal, hat jemand von euch mal die Ehre und hat Red hat Virtualis...
Wie heißt der Kram überhaupt?
Red hat Virtualis...
Late hat
Red hat Virtualisy...
Red hat Virtualis...
...Server oder so verwenden müssen.
Das ist richtig eklig.
Das ist mässig, massive eklig.
Ich musste das nur mal kurz mir angucken, das hat mir schon gereicht.
Killrock, ich hab keine Ahnung, was du meinst.
Also ja, vor allem bei Workstation kostet was,
aber vor allem bei Workstation kriegst du relativ günstig Lizenzen schon.
Und Chat, ich weiß, man kriegt die Keys irgendwo anders auch,
aber das will ich hier nicht promoten.
Also du kriegst beispielsweise sogar...
bei amazon selbst wenn du amazon suchst vmware workstation lizenzen manchmal aber ansonsten
beim keystore deiner wahl kriegst du auch welche also du musst keine 180 euro oder was das normal
kostet ausgeben und ich finde halt vmware workstation hat die bessere desktop integration
virtualbox geht auch aber gerade was 3d beschleunigung oder generell gpu beschleunigung
in der vm angeht auch einfache snapshot handling generell wie sich das von der qualität wie sich
das anfühlt desktop virtualisierung würde ich immer vmware workstation vorziehen im server
bereich klar da gibt es bestimmt sogar daseinsberechtigung für hyper-v und solche
komischen konstrukte wobei ich ehrlich gesagt ganz ganz im ernst wenn ich serverseite
hauptsächlich virtualisieren müsste würde ich vmware nehmen würde ich auch esx nehmen oder aber
im heimbereich kann man natürlich auch so was wie proxmox oder so benutzt spricht ja nix dagegen ja
oder eine ubuntu server mit virtmanager drauf nein vmware workstation hat kein gpu passthrough das
liegt daran weil es halt oberhalb von windows läuft ich weiß kvm kann das auch aber kvm kann
das nur weil es linux only ist und es die passenden module hat das haben sie aber
das haben sie unter windows noch nicht hinbekommen leider es wäre mega nice könnte vor allem bei
workstation nicht nicht dass ich mist erzähle und es hat sich mittlerweile geändert aber ich bin mir
relativ sicher das geht nicht was moment das nut support hätte mich jetzt auch hätte mich jetzt
auch sehr gewundert ja ja genau hätte mich jetzt nämlich auch gewundert wenn sich da was geändert
hat das ist tatsächlich ein vorteil
wenn du windows unter linux virtualisierst mit kvm und gpu passthrough dafür hast du dann andere
probleme du hattest mal gezeigt ja ich habe die bei so einer richtig hässlichen seite gekauft wo
ich nie wieder was bestellen würde weil die so shady aussieht will ich jetzt nicht zeigen ja
esxi kann passthrough esxi läuft aber nicht unter windows esxi ist sein eigenes betriebssystem das
ist ja auch der große unterschied dazwischen das ist quasi on top auf windows und das ist quasi
unten drunter und du hast dann dein windows vielleicht oder dein linux in der vm das kann das
tatsächlich cool wenn du kvm oder linux verwendest dass sie das halt auch im laufenden system können
was du sonst verwendest der anderen seite ganz im ernst die gpu passthrough ist eh nicht so das
allergeilste gerade wenn du den bildschirm dann nicht mal vom desktop verwenden kannst was du
natürlich machen kannst wofür es halt echt nice ist die ganzen grafikkarten die haben ja auch
hardware video decoder und das wäre natürlich sehr praktisch weil ich zeige euch das mal wir machen
das hier mal hat auch auf und ich gehe hier beispielsweise auf youtube und machen ein
video von mir auf okay das liegt 2 ich geupdatet habe ist ein bisschen lahm gerade bis ich neu
gestartet habe so jetzt mach ich mal ein video anbola ich schieb mal kurz jedes terminal rüber
waren mein video an und schalten wir mal wirklich ordentlich hoch 1080p da sieht man halt schon da
braucht ganz gut cpu warum braucht er gut cpu und er braucht übrigens umso mehr cpu so größer das ganze
logisch der profil cpu weil das ding komplett cpu decodet wird vor allem
workstation unter linux nein ich verwende kein kvm die verwenden ihren
eigenen krempel ja das ist halt das wäre tatsächlich so
einer der wenigen gründe warum ich sagen würde hey eine grafikkarte irgendwie
durchgereicht in die vm wäre cool weil ein hardware video decoder macht den
browser an vielen stellen oder generell hat auch grafiker grafikkarte macht den
browser und das surfen um ein vielfaches schneller aber ansonsten kannst du das
natürlich kannst du das auslagern das ist doch das was normalerweise passiert
schau mal das geht jetzt nicht weil ich hier keine grafikkarte in der vm ab oder
zumindest keine richtige grafikkarte sondern nur so eine fake grafikkarte
guck mal wenn du hier guckst in die detail oder wo immer man performance
sieht man es glaube ich nicht ach du
scheiße windows ansicht zumindest wir nehmen jetzt mal chromium und gehen mal
auf youtube da wirst du sehen dass es wahrscheinlich relativ unter ubuntu ja
unter linux wird es ein bisschen schwieriger unter linux geht es
mittlerweile auch ganz gut aber da brauchst du die richtige kombination aus
browser mesa 3 bahn also die richtigen version richtige kernel version ganz
ehrlich gpu decoding von videos unter linux ist so ein ding das geht aber es müssen so die
sterne im richtigen winkel stehen dass das klappt so aber unter windows ist das
seit jahren ja schon so wenn ich jetzt hierhin gehe wird man sehen das braucht
relativ viel cpu last mein chromium relativ geht's so aber wenn ich das
gleiche mal nehme und gehen in den echten chrome und startet das gleiche video mal
max hat man die klage und jetzt werdet ihr sehen das ding braucht nichts kommt
mal ja okay ähnlich ähnlich viel also aber im vergleich im vergleich zu meiner linux kiste
nix und man sieht auch dass ihr die gpu ganz gut dabei ist und der linux habe ich 80 prozent cpu
last hier plus 13 also das wäre schon cool wenn man irgendwie aus diesen gründen eine grafiker
in mit vm workstation durchschleifen konnte aber geht nicht und ganz ehrlich so essentiell
ist es auch nicht weil ich gucke im endeffekt keine kaum so gut wie keine video sind da vor
allem wird also hätten wir hätten wir das erledigt ja also warum kein fan mehr von unity er nicht von
unify nicht unity also das muss ich wahrscheinlich öfters beantworten deswegen sage ich das gleich mal
am anfang ich habe es gestern ja auch schon erzählt
also es gibt ein großes feature wo ich echt enttäuscht bin von unify dass sie das davon von
ubiquity dass sie das hat nach jahren immer noch nicht unterstützen das hätte ich gerne aber es
kommen noch paar andere sachen dabei die ich auch nicht schön finde also das erste ist dass ich mit
der generellen qualität der access point nicht so wirklich zufrieden bin ich habe teilweise
verbindungsabbrüche unerklärlich man weiß nicht genau warum und ich habe auch schon so ziemlich
alles optimiert was dort optimierung machen kannst ja ich habe die channel
manuell verteilt ich habe die die unify optimierung ausgeschaltet ich habe die position der access
points passen hat ich habe die sendeleistung runter gedreht dass ich das kann man sie so gut wie gar
nicht mehr überschneidet aber trotzdem gerade bei dem auf der außenseite voraus habe ich öfters
mal verbindungsabbrüche keine ahnung warum aber damit könnte ich im endeffekt noch leben der
nächste punkt ist also wir arbeiten uns jetzt mal so ein bisschen vor von den punkten die ich nervig
kacke finde, dass es die nicht gibt. Das nächste
ist der Unify-Controller.
Ich bin nie warm geworden mit dem Ding.
Ich habe prinzipiell nichts dagegen, dass man
einen Controller braucht, aber ich mag den Unify-Controller
nicht. Erstens finde ich die Settings
da drin verwirrend.
Außerdem haben sie viele Auto-Optimierungen,
die mir auf den Keks gehen. Die kann man
dann zig Umwege, die sich bei jeder Version
ändern, irgendwie ein- und ausschalten.
Aber viele Dinger im Unify-Controller sind
finde ich
wie soll ich sagen, nicht griffig benannt.
Und das ist so, als möchte
Ubiquiti da so auf zwei Hochzeiten tanzen.
Auf der einen Seite möchte man sich quasi
an so etwas
höherpreisige Heimanwender
richten und benennt deswegen
die Sachen, sagen wir mal, easy.
Auf der anderen Seite möchte man sich eben an Leute
richten, die ein bisschen mehr machen wollen.
Aber gerade da würde es helfen, wenn man die Dinger
eben ordentlich benennt.
Ich bin kein Fan vom
Unify-Controller.
Und das, was mich da eigentlich am meisten an dem
Controller aufregt, ist, ich habe den ja auch
auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen,
dass er mir schon nach zwei Updates mal nicht mehr gestartet
ist. Bei dem einen Mal hat er irgendwelche
Schmerzen gehabt mit der Java-Version
und dann hat er noch irgendwelche
Schmerzen gehabt mit, glaube ich, übrig gebliebenen
Zertifikaten von der Vorgänger. Keine Ahnung,
frag mich nicht. Ich konnte es alles fixen,
aber abfuck.
Und was mich aber am meisten nervt an dem
Controller, beziehungsweise an dem, wie das
bei Unify funktioniert,
in Verbindung mit dem Controller ist,
dass wenn du ein WLAN hast,
wenn du ein WLAN eingerichtet hast, ja,
beispielsweise ein Test-WLAN,
und du aktivierst das wieder,
dann muss jeder
Access-Point rebooten.
Das allein
wäre ja gar nicht so extrem schlimm.
Das Dumme ist nur,
dass das teilweise
ewig dauert.
Also es braucht 40
Sekunden und bis zu einer Minute teilweise,
bis die Access-Points wieder richtig erreichbar sind,
bei so einem Reprovisioning.
Dann connecten sich natürlich
alle
WLAN-Geräte im Haus neu
zu unterschiedlichen Access-Points,
weil die unterschiedlich schnell booten und unterschiedlich schnell
wieder hochkommen. Es sei denn, du pinst
explizit deine Geräte, was dann auch
fragwürdig ist bei manchen, also gerade
bei Smartphones.
Und dann dauert das
wieder zwei Tage, bis sich das eingependelt hat
und alles wieder an seinem richtigen Access-Point hängt.
Das ist nervig. Also dieses ewige
Rum-Reboote geht mir wirklich mega auf den Sack.
Dann hatte ich noch das Problem, dass die nur so ganz
merkwürdiges PoE unterstützt haben.
Eine Zeit lang. Mittlerweile unterstützen
die stinknormales, frag mich nicht,
802.11.af
oder was ist der PoE-Standard?
802.3.af
links.
Ursprünglich hatten die mal Probleme
und gingen nur mit ihrem komischen eigenen Injektor,
aber sei es drum.
Und das eigentliche Feature,
was mir persönlich fehlt ist,
warum ich mir jetzt auch
zwei Access-Points noch von Ebay geholt habe,
ist, ich möchte
eigene Passwörter,
pro Gerät vergeben für das WLAN.
Warum? Weil ich
habe ein Gäste-WLAN, ich habe ein
normales Geräte-WLAN
und ich habe ein IoT-WLAN.
Das IoT-WLAN
hat für jedes Gerät das
gleiche Passwort. Und das finde ich
kacke. Da gibt es Möglichkeiten.
So gut wie jeder andere Hersteller
kann das. Ich rede jetzt nicht von
WPA Enterprise, wohlgemerkt, weil
IoT-Geräte, die können kein
WPA Enterprise. TP-Link
Omada kann das auch mittlerweile.
Seit März können die das aber erst.
So, ähm,
so, und das
ist doof. Und das ist ein Feature
gerade für Leute, die viel
IoT-Geräte haben, was
tatsächlich fehlt.
Und Unify hat
schon Feature-Requests seit
Jahren offen. Es gibt sogar Leute,
die haben das selbst nachgebaut, aber das kannst
du halt komplett knicken. Das willst du nicht.
Das willst du nicht haben.
Remember your Duo with Thunder?
Yes, that's, äh,
I think about
10 years ago?
Good Call of Duty times.
Must be around Modern Warfare 2
or Black Ops 1?
Das war geil, Leute. Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
So, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, also es gibt ja Leute,
die haben das versucht nachzubauen.
Das mit dem
IoT geht mittlerweile über UID.
Das ist jetzt sehr, äh,
random. Das musst du mir ein bisschen genauer
erklären, was du damit meinst.
Also,
gerade für
Unify
habe ich nichts gefunden in dieser Richtung
und mich würde es hart wundern,
wenn es das gibt, weil
die Diskussion,
dass es nicht gibt und Unify das nicht einbauen
will, sind gerade mal 2-3
Wochen alt. So, zumindest
es haben Leute nachgebaut.
Ja, gut.
Da brauchst du irgendeine extra, da brauchst du
noch irgendeinen extra Router oder so von Unify
dabei. Ja, das ist ja
natürlich bescheuert, dass man das, das, das,
das beknackt. Warum geht sowas nicht über den Controller?
Aber wir gucken uns
das mal, wir gucken uns das mal kurz an.
Was sie da
haben.
Ich werde mir garantiert, ich werde mir garantiert
keine, äh, Tree Machine daheim
mehr hinstellen jetzt. Das kannst du knicken. Aber wir gucken uns
das Ganze mal an. Getting started.
Unify Identification.
Early Access.
Chillfreak, das machen wir heute.
Okay, das muss man uns gerade mal...
Also, UID ist eine
Identity as a Service.
Alter, die Abkürzungen werden echt immer hängen geblieben,
oder?
Oh, Gott.
IDAS.
IDAS. Gut.
Cloud-Based Identity
Output. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist was anderes.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist nicht das, was ich meine.
Edit, remove users quickly.
Secure, manage user access.
Connect your...
Verify...
...registered users, devices...
Ähm, das klingt mir eher
nach irgendeinem WPA-Enterprise-Geschichte.
Nicht nach normalem
WPA-Pre-Shared-Key.
Ach so.
UID is currently supporting United States
and Canada. Okay, da hat sich das ja mit da schon mal
erledigt. Da müssen wir jetzt mal
schauen, inwieweit sich das vergleichen lässt.
Aber für mich sieht das aus, als sind das zwei
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Alter, was?
Was?
Nee, nee, nee. Ganz bestimmt.
Im Leben nicht. Im Leben nicht.
Werde ich mir sowas holen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das scheint mir was
gänzlich anderes zu sein. Aber wir können uns ja mal
kurz das Video zu angucken.
Sollen wir es auch noch lauter machen, weil
die ihren Sound nicht im Griff haben.
Ah, wo ist mein Sound?
Da.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das ist was, das geht in die ganz andere
Richtung. Das ist eher sowas
wie Zero-Auth oder so
irgend so einen
globalen
Identity-Service. Das ist glaube ich ganz
was anderes.
Nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee. Das ist was anderes.
Ja, okay. Nee, nee. Das ist was anderes.
Wie gesagt, es ist auch das
Geheule schon seit Jahren groß, dass das
Unify nicht
implementiert. Und das ist der Hauptgrund, den ich
haben will. Warum ich
was anderes haben will. Ich habe saumäßig
viele IoT-Geräte am Start.
Wir haben letztens in mein DHCP geguckt. Ich hatte
in den letzten paar Monaten, oder sagen wir mal so,
die letzten zwei, drei
Jahre, 85
Geräte im WLAN.
Oder 75.
Ich weiß nicht. 85 oder 75.
Und davon sind natürlich
nicht mal alle an. Aber daran
sieht man es ja schon. Wenn man
IoT-Geräte wegschmeißt, schmeißt man
sein WLAN-Passwort in den Müll.
Und das finde ich doof. Deswegen
finde ich diese Variante, was andere Hersteller
haben, dass du WLAN-Passwörter
vergeben kannst pro Gerät.
Eine super Geschichte.
Wie gesagt, WPA-Enterprise ist
was anderes. Das muss das Endgerät unterstützen.
Hier geht es darum, dass billige
WLAN-Steckdosen ein eigenes
Passwort bekommen können für das gleiche
WLAN.
Ah, wo ist meine...
Jetzt drüber scrollen.
Kennt ihr mal einen guten Channel, der gleich mal ein gut C lernen kann?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mir keine C-Tutorials auf YouTube angeguckt
bisher.
Ne, die VM kann nicht auf die GPU zugreifen.
Die VM hat eine eigene GPU,
also eine virtualisierte GPU,
die mittlerweile, und das sollte
man auch machen, du kannst in den
VMware-Settings hier ein Häkchen machen
bei Display.
Kannst du sagen, accelerate 3D-Graphics.
Das ist ganz praktisch. Dann kann das
Ding sogar OpenGL und in etwas,
älteres DirectX unter Windows.
Das bringt schon einiges,
aber ist natürlich nicht damit zu vergleichen
mit einer durchgereichten
Grafikkarte, und leider können
die keine Videodecoder
durchreichen. Ja,
ich auch, dafür habe ich es zum größten Teil.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was
die da... Ja, also welche
Access-Points habe ich mir jetzt gekauft?
Also ich habe ja tatsächlich das
letzte Mal ein bisschen geliebäugelt,
wobei ich muss da gar nicht auf Ebay,
ein bisschen geliebäugelt, ob ich mal das
WTP-Link-Zeug nicht mal antesten soll.
Aber...
Ich habe mir jetzt gedacht, wir machen was anderes.
Und zwar, ich habe mir zum Testen
einen etwas älteren
hiervon gekauft. Die sehen so aus.
Mit dem werden wir uns heute auch ein bisschen ausprobieren, so ein Teil.
Das ist die
vorletzte Generation. Also
sprich, das ist
802.11ac
Wave 1.
Ach, frag mich nicht. Ist nicht das
schnellste, ist auch nicht
mehr supported, ist end of life mittlerweile
bei denen. Aber zum Testen ist es ein ganz gutes
Ding. Und zum wirklich Betreiben habe ich
mir relativ günstig auf Ebay
so einen... Moment.
So einen bekommen. Für 260
Euro oder sowas.
270 Euro, irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Die Dinger kosten neu 1300.
Das ist ein fucking Access-Point.
Für 1367
Euro.
Das ist viel, viel zu teuer.
Würde ich niemals neu kaufen.
Und die neuen von denen,
die bewegen sich tatsächlich in diesen Preisregionen.
Ja, also wenn man sich beispielsweise
einen AX kaufen will, auch
1000 Euro in dem Dreh. Also das
sind die allerneuesten. Mit Wifi 6, also
802.11ax
Also das, was umgangssprachlich
so unter Wifi 6 läuft.
Was ich übrigens
sehr big brain von dieser
Wifi Alliance finde,
dass sie das Wifi 6
genannt haben. Beziehungsweise sie haben mit Wifi 5
schon angefangen. Jetzt mit Wifi 6
die machen das richtig. Die USB
Leute benennen ihren USB-Kram
unsinnig, sodass es kein Sau versteht.
Und die sind schlau bei der Wifi Alliance.
Die haben gesagt, kein Noob.
Checked.
IEEE 802.11ax
Und
daraufhin hat man gesagt, man nennt das einfach Wifi 6.
Das ist eigentlich das Beste, was man
machen konnte. Das ist ein griffiger
Marketingbegriff im Endeffekt, wo die Leute
was mit anfangen können.
Ja.
So, das sind die ganz Neuen. Und die Dinger sind halt
saumäßig teuer. Deswegen habe ich mir auf
Ebay
so einen bestellt.
Die haben auch noch aktuelle Firmware.
Obwohl die offiziell glaube ich nicht mehr hergestellt werden.
Und es ist für mich daheim
hoffe ich mal
möglich, wenn ich den in Flur hänge,
dass ich das ganze Haus inklusive Terrasse damit
abdecke mit einem Access Point.
Ich komme damit vielleicht nicht mehr so weit
in den Garten rein, wie mit dem Unified Zeug.
Aber ganz ehrlich, im Garten schalte ich dann einfach
oder switch das Smartphone dann halt auf Mobile.
Ja, weil ich aus dem Garten
nicht auf irgendwelche internen Sachen zugreifen kann,
soll mir recht sein.
Macht mein Setup einfacher
und ich habe dann Features, die ich haben will
und insgesamt auch einen besseren Access Point.
So.
Den habe ich mir gekauft. Also ich habe mir einen R600
gekauft und einen R710.
Den R710, den probiere ich im Offstream aus.
Heute basteln wir mit dem
R600 rum.
Ich muss noch kurz was trinken.
Ich glaube, ich habe zu lange gelabert, dass
man das klippen könnte.
Nein, ich kaufe mir keinen Access Point
für 1.300.
Ich habe doch gerade gesagt, ich habe mir den für 270 Euro
bei Ebay gekauft, gebraucht.
Also die Dinger finde ich
nice. Gerade das, was ich gesehen habe.
Ich bin ein bisschen hinten dran.
Also wie gesagt, wir haben mal nachgeguckt,
das ist was anderes.
Ja, ich verstehe generell nicht,
warum die Leute teilweise so scharf drauf sind,
alles über die Cloud zu machen.
Gerade, wenn man dann so Sachen
mitbekommt wie für
Smart Home Geräte, wo Hersteller
komplett den Betrieb eingestellt haben
und die Geräte gar nicht mehr funktionieren.
Wie hießen die?
Insteon oder so?
Was Home Assistant jetzt übernommen hat.
Insteon, genau.
So, die haben
einfach
April 2022
sind die quasi pleite gegangen oder so,
und alle Leute,
die sich Geräte von denen gekauft haben,
waren erstmal,
wie sagt man so schön heutzutage,
gefickt.
Die konnten erstmal nichts machen.
Also deswegen verstehe ich das nicht.
Oder es gab doch auch schon öfters Probleme,
ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, von 2 Jahren,
wo AWS mal geruckelt hat,
so ein paar Stunden lang,
dass dann manche Leute die smarte Thermostat
hatten und nicht mehr ihre Heizung bedienen konnten.
Da hört es bei mir auf. Also ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich eine Internetanbindung und eine Funktion
hersteller Cloud brauche,
dass meine Heizung geht,
dann ist irgendwas verkehrt.
April, ach stimmt,
vielleicht war das nur ein April Scherz.
Aber der April ist ja vorbei.
Und die sind immer noch weg.
Blue Media sagt,
er findet Unifies vom Low Budget
Enterprise zum typischen Prosumer Crap
montiert. Bin mittlerweile Fan von...
Ja, das umschreibt es eigentlich ganz gut.
Ohne Scheiß, dieser, der
Controller, ich habe mir das letztens mal
angeguckt, die Oberfläche. Also,
das inspiriert von Unify zu nennen,
ist schon fast
eine maßlose
Untertreibung. Also das ist
1 zu 1
copy-pasted von Unify.
Teilweise das Omada UI.
Aber soll mir recht sein, im Endeffekt.
Was juckt's
mich als User, ja?
Wie gesagt, ich habe mir 2 Access Points geholt,
einen R600 zum heute ausprobieren,
einen Dell R710 zum hier daheim verwenden.
Ja.
Windows 11.
Zurück kann ich nichts zu sagen, hatte ich noch nie.
Ja.
Das Gute an den Dingern ist, die haben
nicht nur, sagen wir mal, coole Funktionen,
leider haben die halt so die übliche
Geschichte, die viele Enterprise Anbieter
haben, so nach dem Motto, kauft ihr doch eine Lizenz
für unser Controller für 150
Euro im Monat oder was auch immer.
Nein, kein Dell R710,
einen
Access Point.
Und aber auch nicht
für den Preis, sondern von Ebay gebraucht.
Die Build-Quality von den Dingern soll halt
mega nice sein. Ich persönlich kann's nicht beurteilen.
Also ich habe weder in meine Unify Access Points
reingeguckt selber, noch
hab ich
in den R710 reingeguckt.
Ich habe aber Teardowns gesehen und
sagen wir mal so, die Einschätzung von Leuten dazu gelesen
und von der Build-Quality sollen die
Dinger wirklich mega nice sein.
Unify-Dinger halt preislich
angemessen, was man da bekommt.
Also im Prinzip kann man sich das so
vorstellen, in den Unify, in beiden ist
quasi ein besserer Kleiderbügel drin,
als Antenne.
Nur, dass die anderen halt
wohl deutlich besser isoliert
sind und ein, wie nennen sie
das, äh, äh, proprietäres,
das ist irgendwie so ein proprietäres
Beamforming haben, dass
der Access Point quasi
in Richtung, ich nenn's mal
easy, in Richtung der Geräte
funkt, mit denen er kommunizieren will.
Also, ob ich ein EU-Gerät
gekauft habe, ja und nein.
Ich habe ein US-Gerät gekauft und
ein EU-Gerät. Das heißt, wir müssen
jetzt gleich das US-Gerät
noch Country unlocken.
Aber Spoiler, das habe ich schon mal gemacht
vorm Stream und das funktioniert.
Aber wir machen das gleich nochmal zusammen im Stream.
Da kann ich euch nämlich zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
Man kann US-Geräte
kaufen und sie Country unlocken. Das funktioniert.
Ich hab's ausprobiert, aber das machen wir gleich nochmal zusammen.
Normalerweise
ist es nämlich so, dass US-Geräte
ähm, gar nicht
für den Export gedacht sind. Dass man eigentlich US-Geräte
nur in, nur in, im Kokona
Freedomland betreiben kann.
Und, oder betreiben soll.
Und das dann auch von den Frequenzen und der
Sendeleistung und so gar nicht konform ist
für Deutschland. Dementsprechend
ist es doppelt blöd
eigentlich US-Geräte zu kaufen.
Aber in dem Fall ist es gut.
Es gibt hier beispielsweise
eine GitHub-Seite,
die
das erklärt, wie das funktioniert.
Das werden wir gleich machen. Wir werden gleich das hier
machen. Beziehungsweise
das da.
Obtain Root Shell. Dazu müssen wir erstmal
die Firmware downgraden,
ähm, uns Root-Rechte
besorgen, dann
das Country unlocken. Wie gesagt, ich hab das
im Vorfeld schon ausprobiert, das funktioniert, aber wir machen es trotzdem gleich
nochmal zusammen.
Access Point Ungleich
Router. In der Regel
also, sagen wir mal so,
das sind zwei unterschiedliche Funktionen.
Es ist oftmals so, dass Geräte
ein bisschen beides können.
Ja, bestes Beispiel ist die Fritzbox
dafür. Die hat ja nicht nur Router
und Access Point, die hat ja auch noch Deck-Server,
Billig, NAS
und tausende andere Funktionen.
DVB-C-Tuner, alle tausende Funktionen eingebaut.
Ähm, und
ein
Access Point gibt es bestimmt auch
genug, die Routen können zwischen
internem Interface, zwischen Interface und dem
WLAN im Netzwerk, also ich denke mal
das überschneidet sich zum größten Teil, aber es sind
zwei, sind auf jeden Fall zwei komplett
getrennte Funktionen.
Ja, Access Point ist quasi
für Layer 1 und 2, könnte man
so sagen, also quasi für die
Übertragung über die Luft, ja,
per Funk, äh,
und für die Kommunikation
zwischen auf, auf, ja,
auf Layer 2 Ebene, also
auf das, was dann quasi WLAN ist,
und
dann solche Sachen wie
von einem Netz
ins andere Netz kommen, dann
brauchst du einen Router für. Wäre es
sinnvoll einen Standalone-Router zu
holen oder eine Kombi, das kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Die meisten Leute kommen ohne
Probleme hin mit einer poppligen Fritzbox daheim,
die alles in einem Gerät macht.
Tja, ich weiß es nicht, ich verstehe
eh nicht so genau, was das USB-Konsortium
da treibt. Äh,
das könnte ich wahrscheinlich machen,
ja, das ist richtig. Wahrscheinlich,
du hast recht, wahrscheinlich könnte ich
die alten Access-Points, äh,
Access-Points irgendwie als, aber,
pff, werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Was, warum lecke ich
Critical Information?
Wie gesagt, kein UniFi mehr, habe ich gerade ausführlich,
ausführlich erklärt.
In ganz, ganz kurz für alle Leute, die jetzt noch
dabei gekommen sind, also aktuell habe ich
UniFi am Start mit 4 Access-Points,
Erdgeschoss, Keller, erster Stock, und dann
ein raus, Garten, Terrasse.
Ähm, mir fehlen Features,
die ich gerne hätte, wo UniFi keinen Bock hat, die
drauf einzubauen, wo seit Jahren schon
Feature-Requests und Sachen auf sind, die alle anderen
Hersteller im etwas, sagen wir mal,
höherpreisigen Segment können,
und auch günstigere können, auch
Newcomer können, ähm, wo UniFi
keinen Bock drauf hat. Außerdem
habe ich
Connection-Probleme mit einem der Access-Points, und ich bin
auch kein großer Fan des UniFi-Controllers.
Aber hauptsächlich
fehlen mir Features für meine IoT-Geräte,
die ich unbedingt haben will,
und UniFi keinen Bock drauf hat.
Ja, die Dinger sind, deswegen
bin ich letztendlich auch bei dem Hersteller gelandet,
weil egal, wo du guckst,
natürlich wird sich drüber
beschwert, dass die komische Lizenzpraktiken haben
und sowas, wer hat das im Enterprise-Umfeld nicht,
aber dass wohl Build-Quality
und die generelle Qualität der Access-Points
wirklich mit das Beste sein muss, was es gibt.
Also quasi,
wie sagt man so, der Benchmark,
nee, keine Ahnung, also, ähm,
sogar so, dass halt sogar
Cisco-Fans sagen, hey,
ich verwende mittlerweile lieber diesen Hersteller als
Cisco selbst. Also da scheint schon
was dran zu sein. Ich hab da eine ganze Weile auf
Reddit gelesen, in verschiedenen Netzwerken,
äh, Subs, Subreddits
und Admin-Subreddits, was zu den
unterschiedlichen Herstellern. Hab mir auch die
Features ein bisschen verglichen, wer was kann.
Leider können halt viele Hersteller
interessante Features nur mit Cloud-Anbindung
oder besser gesagt, die günstigeren
Geräte, die man halbwegs erschwinglich bekommt,
sind nur die mit Cloud-Anbindung.
Oder man braucht irgendeinen Controller, der dann irgendwie
2000 Euro im Jahr kostet.
Das wollte ich alles nicht
haben. Und diese Ruckus-Dinger
kann man standalone ohne Controller
betreiben mit allen wichtigen Features, die ich habe.
Und die sollen halt auch eine wirklich
gute Qualität haben vom Gerät
selber. Das werden wir heute mal
ausprobieren. Wohlgemerkt nicht
mit einem R750, weil ein R750
kostet auch wieder, keine Ahnung,
1500 Euro oder so.
Ja, ein Schnapper. 1500 Euro
Access Point. Also der muss ja auch gut
sein für den Preis, ansonsten wird das keiner kaufen.
Das hab ich nicht. Wie gesagt,
ich hab einen R600 zum Testen und einen
R710. Das ist quasi der
Vor...
Vorgänger? Gab's noch einen R700?
R720 kann sein.
Also ich hab quasi Last Gen.
Das ist Current Gen,
ich hab Last Gen. Dafür kostet
Last Gen quasi nur ein Achtel
vom Preis her auf Ebay
und ist für daheim vollkommen ausreichend.
Die sind nicht
insteon, die sind insteoff. Richtig.
Ja, nice.
Ja, mein R600, den ich zum Testen gekauft hab,
der bekommt keine Updates mehr, aber das macht ja nix.
Entity Framework. Ja, geht so.
Kenn ich mich halbwegs brauchbar mit aus.
Aber Entity Framework Core, ne?
Also nicht .NET 4.8
EF6
oder so.
Wenn ich eine Cloud für meine Heizung bräuchte, hätte ich echt
Probleme. Mein Internet verabschiedet sich. Ja,
ist so.
Wie gesagt, wir flashen das gleich um.
Hast du schon mal OPC UA Server?
Nein. Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Kommt drauf an.
In
2,4 GHz Band gibt es glaube
ich nur... Gibt es denn
für Channels, die sich nicht überlagern?
6 Channels oder irgendwie sowas?
In 5 GHz gibt es
mehr. Und das ist auch pro Land
unterschiedlich.
Oder so. Genau.
Also. Und die überschneiden sich ja auch.
Also im Prinzip hast du ja 1 bis 14, wobei
14 keiner die verwendet kann. Bis 11
du hast 1 bis 11, genau.
Ähm...
Bei uns ist glaube ich auch so, dass man
das nicht...
Also ich kann auch glaube ich
nur bis 11 auswählen, ja. Und die
überschneiden sich auch so weit, dass es im Endeffekt
genau, dass es im Endeffekt quasi
1, 6 und 11 gibt.
Ähm...
Wenn du wirklich willst, dass
sich nichts überschneidet. Also genau. 1, 6 und 11.
Also hast du quasi 3 Channels
für 2,4. Bei dem anderen
hast du noch ein bisschen mehr.
Bei 5 GHz.
Jo.
Da musst du jetzt gucken, wie das beispielsweise in
Deutschland ist, weil das ja auch nicht in
allen Ländern gleich ist.
Wann kommt der Nachfolger
von 5 GHz eigentlich für Wifi?
Die Frequenz
hat nicht unbedingt was mit dem Wifi-Standard
zu tun.
Also die ersten, keine Ahnung, 5,
6 Wifi-Standards waren alle auf
2,4 GHz.
Dann gab es irgendwann noch 5 GHz
dazu. Und jetzt ist man am überlegen,
ob nicht noch irgendwie mal irgendwann
6 GHz dabei kommt. Aber das macht
ja auch nichts. Also du kannst ja auch im 5 GHz
Bereich ohne Probleme
neue Techniken verwenden.
Ja genau. Das kommt jetzt dabei,
wie gesagt, 2,4 und 5 gibt's
ja weiter. Und nur weil ein neues
Frequenzband dazu kommt, heißt das nicht, dass
das irgendwie
ein neuer WLAN-Standard nicht auch was bringen würde
für die alten Frequenzen.
Ja gerade so Sachen wie Beamforming, wo sie
jetzt auch bei
Wifi 6 glaube ich viel gemacht haben,
also dass du quasi ein bisschen besser
in Richtung des Geräts funken kannst,
wo das
was das haben will,
das ist schon eine coole Geschichte.
Ja, komm. Also,
Wifi 6e ist ja nun
wirklich noch ganz neu. Du hast doch kaum Geräte,
die das unterstützen. Du hast jetzt die ersten
Router, die gab's aber schon, bevor das überhaupt
standardisiert ist. Das ist wirklich
sehr, sehr neu.
Da ist auch schon Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu.
Oh, es gibt noch nicht mal, doch es gibt
Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was man
da aktuell, welche,
keine Ahnung, ob überhaupt aktuelle Smartphones schon
6e unterstützen. Also das ist wirklich ganz, ganz
neu.
Gut, haben wir das geklärt?
Erzähl, was du wissen willst, wegen
Entity Framework.
Okay, also, wir haben geupdatet.
Browser, update, ich
reboote mal kurz. Ich mach nochmal hier ein Update
und dann fangen wir an.
Also wie gesagt,
für den Test heute verwenden wir den hier.
Den hab ich mir extra beste...
Okay, ich mach's nachher auf.
Visual Studio
aktualisieren, alles klar.
Okay, Moment. Was kann ich?
JS-60, JS-68,
Linux... Moment, Linux
Latest?
Soll ich das wirklich aninstallen?
Ich bin mir... Warum hab ich
einen Wiedertreiber?
Okay, Reise-FS brauchen wir nur wirklich
nimmer. Sekunde, Leute,
die Musik nervt mich. Ich muss mal etwas entspannenderes
anmachen. Wollen wir da...
Ja, das ist gut hier.
Excellent.
Moin.
Passwort, massive Passwort. Kommt nie einer drauf
hier auf mein Passwort.
Äh, hallo?
Soll ich Linux Latest deinstallieren? Ist das wirklich
so eine gute Idee?
Mal gucken, welchen Kernel ich hab. Nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie
was gelöscht hab.
Installed, Recommended...
So einen alten Kernel... Was hab ich denn
hier für nur alten Kernel drauf?
MonkaS, was ist das denn?
Yes.
LTS, Recommended, LTS...
Na, zumindest mal eine LTS-Version
können wir mal upgraden hier.
LTS ist ja immer schön und gut.
Aber...
510, das ist ja von 2000...
Keine Ahnung.
20 oder so.
Machen Snapshot.
Ach was, YOLO.
Okay, wie gut.
Äh, ja, man muss sagen,
5G und 5Ghz
WLAN hat miteinander nichts zu tun.
Das eine ist Mobilfunk.
Die fünfte Generation Mobilfunk.
Und das andere ist
5Ghz WLAN.
Das ist leider
aktuell etwas missverständlich für viele,
was ich verstehen kann, weil halt 5 und es geht dann
mit G weiter. Aber bei dem einen sind es
5Ghz und bei dem anderen ist es die fünfte
Generation.
Das ist leider ein bisschen...
Ja.
Missverständlich.
Deswegen finde ich es gut, dass es Wifi 5 und Wifi 6
heißt. Und spätestens mit
Wifi 6 hat sich das Missverständnis dann
eh erledigt. So, wir haben rebooted.
Okay, können wir mal anfangen. Gut.
Was muss ich denn machen müssen?
Also ich habe zum Testen, wie gesagt, ein R600
hier als Access Point.
Ich mach mal ein Bild auf, weil ich mir ziemlich sicher bin.
Das wäre ich heute noch öfters
öfters gefragt, habe ich ein schönes
HiRes Bild davon.
HiRes Bild. Ja, so sieht der aus.
HiRes. HiRes genug.
Passt. So.
Scheiße aus das Bild.
HiRes.
Moment.
Ordentliches, ordentliches Foto davon.
Ich kann meine Kamera anmachen.
Large.
Super large. Jawohl.
Ja, also das ist der Access Point.
Eigentlich ist die interessante Seite vorne.
Weil der vorne
die ganzen
LEDs hat. Aber hier ist, ist auch
okay. Okay, jetzt lasse ich mal so auf, als wenn alle wissen, welchen
Access Point wir heute testen. Dann den.
Wie gesagt, verwenden werde ich den R710
nicht, den hier. Aber zum Ausprobieren ist das hier eigentlich ganz gut.
So, dann brauchen wir
den Country Unlock,
weil ich habe ein US-Gerät gekauft.
US-Geräte sind
normalerweise nicht für den Export gedacht.
Aber der Hersteller war so nett und hat
eine Hintertür offen gelassen, dass man die Sachen
auf andere Countries an
anlocken, beziehungsweise
ummappen kann. Dazu müssen
wir aber die Firmware downgraden.
Das heißt, was wir jetzt machen werden ist
folgendes. Als erstes
müssen wir uns einen Raspberry Pi
flashen, weil wir
ein Gerät brauchen, von dem wir dann auf den Access Point
gehen, beziehungsweise wo wir dann
auch als WLAN Gerät zum testen.
Ausprobieren. Also Flash und Raspberry
Pi. Dann
werkt, oder sagen wir Factory,
Factory Default den
AP. Was ich hier nicht vergessen
darf ist Default User
und PWE, weil das ist ja mittlerweile
neu. Es gibt ja
kein Default User und Passwort mehr. Eine der
dümmsten Entscheidungen ever.
Ich weiß, sie mussten das aufgrund
irgendwelche Richtlinien machen, aber es ist
richtig, richtig, richtig dumm.
Was ist mit dem Price Champ?
Der Price Champ ist down.
Absichtlich down.
Ähm
RIP
Genau. So. Factory
Desert Access Point. Dann
ähm Firmware
Firmware
Downgrade. Scheiß auf
Rechtschreibfehler. Firmware
Downgrade. Dann machen
wir Country
Country Unlock.
Dann Update auf
Neuste Unleashed
Firmware. Neuste in Anführungszeichen,
weil für den R600 ist es die
neueste Firmware von letztem Jahr.
Ähm und
dann äh Wifi
einrichten.
Beziehungsweise Setup.
Wifi einrichten
und dann äh
testen mit dem Raspberry Pi.
So. Das probieren wir heute mal aus.
So. Das heißt als erstes
brauche ich
Nein. Nicht Command Bra
Rechamp. Hab ich
das gemappt auf irgendeine Taste?
Irgendwie habe ich das gerade per Shortcut ausgelöst.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass ich das gemappt habe.
So. Also das heißt als erstes muss ich
meinen Raspberry Pi flashen. Das ist doch easy.
Äh Pi Imager
Wo ist meine SSD?
Hier. SSD
Komm mal her. Also wir probieren
das jetzt gleich mal richtig
äh in your face aus.
Die Raspberry Pi 4s
die können mittlerweile angeblich alle
ohne Umwege
von SSD booten.
Musik ist mir viel zu laut.
Warum ist das so laut?
Also die Pi's die können
alle von SSD booten. Deswegen testen
wir das jetzt mal. Ob das auch alles
so easy funktioniert.
Ich werde jetzt einfach das Image
auf die SSD klatschen und dann den Raspberry Pi
starten und dann gucken ob alles funktioniert.
Moment. Festplatte
anschließen. Festplatte
anschließen.
Ist das jetzt dran?
Boot.
Nein. Nein. Nein. Nein.
Nein. Nein. Nein.
Äh.
Was davon ist meine SSD?
Moment. Ich muss meine SSD in die
VM kriegen. Warum?
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder los?
Alter.
Warum geht das nicht?
Monka.
SHD.
Ja welches USB Device ist es denn jetzt?
Ja welches ist es denn jetzt davon?
Aha.
Okay.
Das ist es.
Okay. Alles klar.
Geile Benahmung.
Das da ist es.
InnoStore USB.
InnoStore. Das war nämlich vorher auch nicht da.
Yes.
Meine Güte.
Das immer raus zu bekommen.
So. Ja. Ja. Ja. Passt.
Alles gut.
Okay. Ähm.
Wir können das einfach überprüfen
ob es die richtige Karte ist.
Ähm.
Ob es die richtige SSD ist.
Können wir ganz einfach testen.
Gucken wir mal. Er hat es erkannt als SDB.
Fdisk. Def. SDB.
Zwei äh. Partitionen drauf.
Das ganze ist insgesamt 1,82 Terabyte.
Das kommt ziemlich gut hin.
Und dann
gucken wir nochmal.
Das erste ist gut.
Und das zweite ist ein X4.
Jawohl. Das ist die richtige SSD.
So. Äh.
Sudo Pi Imager.
So.
Leute. 32 Bit
oder 64 Bit. Komm wir machen das 64.
Wir machen das 64 Bit Raspberry Pi drauf.
Macht im Prinzip keinen Unterschied.
Raspberry Pi OS 64 Bit Lite.
Neuer Raspberry Pi.
Nö. Neu ist der nicht.
Den brauchen wir jetzt aber zum basteln.
Äh. Settings.
Enable SSH.
Äh. Passwort. Ja.
Raspberry.
Ich bleib beim Default Passwort.
So. Configure LAN.
Brauchen wir alles nicht. Können wir insgesamt
sagen. Always. Safe.
Good.
Choose Storage. 2 Terabyte.
Das passt auch.
Das ist ne äh.
BX500 SSD.
Right. Yes.
So. Während das Ding flasht
gucken wir nochmal in Chat.
Wie kann ich am besten zuhause einen DNS Server hosten?
Ich hab Unify Gear zuhause. Will mir nicht immer
die IP Adresse von den ganzen Geräten merken.
Ähm. Zwei. Zwei Punkte.
Das sind nämlich zwei. Zwei unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe. Weil. Bei DNS
Server kannst du zwar Namen zu
IPs auflösen. Aber dann musst du dir Namen merken.
Und wenn du unterschiedliche Geräte hast.
Ist das auch nicht unbedingt immer einfach
sich alle Namen zu merken. Also du willst eigentlich
zwei Sachen haben. Du möchtest ein
wie geahnte. Wie auch
immer geartete Liste haben.
Wo einfach drinne steht was deine
Geräte daheim für feste IPs haben.
Beziehungsweise was die für Namen haben.
Sei es in Wiki. Sei es
äh. Manche Leute nehmen auch ne Excel Liste.
Äh. Ein TXT Dokument.
In Notepads. Vollkommen egal. Du möchtest als erstes
eine Liste haben. Wo drinne steht
was deine statischen IPs
daheim für Geräte dahinter stecken. Oder für
DNS Namen. Das nächste ist DNS
Server. Wenn du DNS Server hosten möchtest.
Weil du dafür
Anwendungszwecke hast. Dann ist die
beste Variante. Finde ich.
Weil man. Ja.
Daheim
nicht 1000 Geräte haben möchte.
Äh. Adblock Home.
Tatsächlich. Das ist zwar hauptsächlich
ein. Ad. Ein
DNS Adblocker. Aber. Nicht
Adblock. Ad. Guard Home.
Mein ich. Aber.
Die haben. Auch für den eingebauten
DNS Server.
Ziemlich viele
Funktionen. Die du über das UI
steuern kannst.
Und es ist allemal besser. Als für
jemand der das noch nicht gemacht hat. DNS
Mask. Oder. Oder. Äh.
Tja. Bind.
MonkaS. Daheim
selbst zu wursten.
Also ich muss sagen. Das beste
User Interface. Für ein 085
DNS. Für Heimanwender.
Ist tatsächlich. Sowas wie AdGuard Home.
Windows DNS ist ja mal der
Ober Crap. Alter. Du kannst natürlich
auch. Hast du irgendwie einen Router. Wo du
statische DNS Einträge machen kannst. Kannst
du den genauso. Genauso benutzen. Aber wenn
du einen extra DNS Server haben willst.
Ist das besser als PiHole.
Ich finde die Settings. Die über.
Ähm.
Die. Darüber
hinausgehen.
Neben dem Adblock. Ist AdGuard Home.
Die schönere Lösung. Ja.
Finde ich.
Ansonsten kannst du natürlich auch jeden x
beliebigen DNS Server nehmen die du schon hast.
Sei es statische DNS Einträge in deinem
Router DNS. Oder.
Wo auch immer du
sonst noch DNS bei dir laufen
hast. Kannst du auch machen. Aber
wenn du vielleicht eh schon ein Adblock DNS noch
zusätzlich haben wolltest. Oder eben
was schönes mit UI suchst.
Finde ich AdGuard Home eine schöne Sache.
Weil. Du musst ja die
Adblock Sachen da drinnen nicht verwenden. Wobei ich die
tatsächlich für Mobile Geräte sehr praktisch finde.
Es hat aber schönes
Management UI für den DNS Master
der unten drunter ist. Du kannst Upstream
DNS festlegen pro Client.
Du kannst Sachen blocken pro Client.
Oder du kannst ganz einfach statische DNS
Einträge machen. Und gut ist.
Ist nice. Finde ich.
Das ist Pains Champ.
Ja. Die Singular ist natürlich
insofern recht. Dass
ähm. Es noch
jede Menge andere Management Lösungen
gibt. Um sowas zu machen.
Aber einen IPAM habe ich tatsächlich
auch nicht zu Hause. Ich hatte mal eine Weile
mit dem Gedanken gespielt sowas wie
Netbox oder so zu verwenden. Aber ganz ehrlich.
Für was daheim? Für was?
Meine
Also meine Datenbank.
Meine Datenbank daheim ist. Haupt ist
zu 99% mein DHCP Server
im Router. Wo ich einfach nachgucken
kann. Und mein DHCP
Server hat eh quasi so gut wie bei
allem statische Einträge. Also
Fixed Einträge für
Pro Mac. Mit Kommentarfeld.
Ja. Also
ich habe im Prinzip zu 95%
alles in meinem DHCP Server drinstehen.
Wenn ich was nachgucken muss.
Core DNS habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Das ist irgend so ne super krasse
Cloud Native Geschichte.
Klingt gut. Ja.
Das ist irgendwas in Go programmiertes.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Weil es ist.
Ist es das?
Makefile sieht nicht nach Go aus.
Doch es ist Go.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also ich habe mal
mal mit 48 FPS gestreamt.
Weil du mit 48 FPS die
optimale Kombination hast
aus flüssigem Content
und mehr
Bandbreite pro Bild.
Wenn du 60 FPS hast. Also stell dir vor
du streamst mit 6 Mbit.
Dann hast du bei 60 FPS
für jedes einzelne Bild
weniger Bandbreite zur Verfügung als mit 48.
Und mit 30 FPS ruckelt
der Stream mehr als mit 48.
Der Unterschied zwischen 48 FPS
und 60 ist auch bei schnelleren Games
für den Zuschauer nicht so wirklich zu erkennen.
Aber die
Bildqualität ist finde ich
gerade bei nicht super hohen
Bitraten besser.
Also ich finde 48 FPS
Ich verstehe gar nicht warum nicht mehr Leute mit 48 FPS streamen.
Ich finde 48 FPS
ist die optimale Kombination
aus ähm
Bitrate. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen wir haben Internet in Deutschland.
Da hat nicht jeder irgendwie
16 Mbit plus
ähm leider.
Das ist die optimale Kombination aus
Schärfe der Bilder und
flüssiger Bewegung.
So jetzt schauen wir mal ob der fertig geflasht hat.
Was zum?
Willst du mich verarschen?
Das ist abgekackt oder?
What the fuck?
Was zum Teufel ist denn da los?
Inhostore removable disk
Ja das mache ich jetzt mit der Disk
Die wird jetzt removed.
So Disk ist removed.
Nein
Die Disk ist removed.
Das hat er bloß nicht gecheckt.
Was ist denn das?
Ist der Adapter für den Arsch oder was?
Was ist mit der?
Ich mache mal einen anderen Adapter kurz dran.
Ja aber selbst über USB 2 müsste das
lutschen.
Warum hast du denn erstmal die Pi Imager nicht auf dem Host System?
Weil ich im Prinzip alles
was mich unter Windows abfuckt einfach unter
Linus mache.
Und Kommandozeilenbedienung und solche Sachen flashen
ist was was mich unter Windows abfuckt.
Ähm
Da habe ich noch einen anderen Adapter.
Nehmen wir mal den.
Vielleicht geht es damit besser.
Weiß ich was der für Schmerzen hat ehrlich gesagt.
Also diesen SSD auf USB Adapter
den habe ich seit
Monaten schon hier am Raspberry Pi dran
und der funktioniert ohne Probleme.
So connect to virtual machine
Poggers
Da machen wir das ganze nochmal.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht der ist schon längst fertig flashen
aber ok.
So SDB wunderbar
Next.
Am 64 bit wird es ja nicht gelegen.
Am 64 bit lite.
Choose storage.
Jawoll 2 TB.
Äh Einstellungen
Bla bla bla bla.
Äh right.
Gut.
Gebe ihm.
Das Passwort ist. Ah das sieht schon besser aus.
Das sieht doch schon besser aus jetzt.
Wollte gerade sagen. Was war das denn vorher?
Das Passwort ist 123456.
Ja das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Bisschen praktisch.
Keine Ahnung was der eben für Schmerzen hatte ich weiß nicht.
Alles klar.
Done.
You can now remove.
Ne das machen wir nicht.
Habe ich SSH eingeschaltet Leute?
Egal schauen wir mal kurz.
Ich glaube ich habe SSH eingeschaltet.
Mount Dev SDB 1 nach MNT
MNT
Gibt es da einen SSH File?
Ne Touch SSH.
Kann nix schaden. Sicher ist sicher.
You mount MNT.
Ja ja ich muss Super User sein.
Sync.
Gut.
Dann machen wir das mal in den Raspberry Pi dran.
Und lassen den booten.
Und ich guck mal nebenbei in meinem Router
was der für eine IP bekommt.
Sekunde Leute ich muss mal kurz das Netzteil dran stöpseln.
Netzteil.
Dann brauchen wir hier
das Kabel.
Netzwerk.
Anschluss.
Und.
Ich glaube mir verpasst nichts spannendes.
Er ist an.
Alles klar.
Ich verbinde mich gleich auf den Raspberry Pi.
Und dann schauen wir uns das zusammen an.
Nebenbei Router aufmachen.
Und mal DHCP gucken was das Ding für eine IP bekommt.
Okay warten wir es ab.
Hat noch keine IP gekriegt.
Ich guck jetzt einfach mal zu.
Bis der gebootet hat.
Er bootet auch.
Zumindest blinkt er.
Wie verrückt.
An der Netzwerkschnittstelle.
An der SSD Aktivitätslampe.
Das ist immer gut zu sehen.
Dann funktioniert es nämlich.
Ja Chat.
Warten wir mal bis es gebootet ist.
Du du.
Bootchamp.
Boot Boot Boot Bootchamp.
Ich hab.
Es hat sich gerade ein Ding.
Eine IP geholt.
Der das Poggers heißt.
Haben wir den Raspberry Pi Poggers genannt?
Oder ist das meine VM?
Ah das ist meine VM. Poggers.
Da ist er.
Ich hab ihn.
SSH 1.2.2.1.3.8
Pi Add. Da ist er.
Ja Verification failed.
Piss dich also.
SSH Keygen
Minus R.
Da. Bumm.
Yes.
Raspberry.
So und was ist das erste was man macht?
SSH
Copy ID
Und jetzt kann man sich ohne Passwort einloggen.
So muss man das machen.
Weil ansonsten musst du jedes mal Raspberry Pi
austippen.
Wie kann ich
Pi Hole oder PF Sense
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Oder PF Sense ins Netzwerk einbinden
und gewährleisten das der ganze Traffic über den Pi läuft.
Du hast PF Sense auf deinem Raspberry Pi
oder wie oder wo oder was
Da musst du dein Setup
das genauer beschreiben.
Das kann ich mir jetzt gerade so wenig rein zu machen.
So.
Upt, Install, Git, T-Max, D-Stat
Was auch immer man da so alles gebrauchen konnte.
Erstmal ein Upt Update
vielleicht machen.
Warum ist denn das so lahm?
Das müsste doch eigentlich flutschen auf der SSD hier.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist ja schnarch langsam.
Ah Moment.
Habe ich da einen USB 3 Anschluss?
Zack. Zack.
Ja habe ich, habe ich.
Was ist denn mit der SSD los?
Ist die irgendwie am verrecken oder was?
Ich mein.
Das ist viel zu langsam.
Das testen wir jetzt gleich mal ob die SSD vielleicht am verrecken ist.
Erstmal so Update.
Liegt an der Musik.
Ne die Musik ist eigentlich dafür zuständig
dass man sich viel besser
fokussieren kann.
So wir gucken mal wie schnell der wirklich auf der SSD jetzt schreiben kann.
Mein Lieblings Mini SSD Benchmark.
Weil vor DD habe ich immer Schiss.
Jedes mal wenn ich DD eintippe
mache ich wirklich
Relive so.
Vorm Rechner.
Deswegen was mir persönlich viel lieber ist
ist die Kombination hier.
PV Input
Def 0
Output Blub.Image
Nö.
Naja aber immer noch schnell genug oder?
Ich mein SSD Geschwindigkeit an USB 3
ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so krass berauschend.
Aber.
Das kann auf jeden Fall reichen.
So haben wir unseren Raspberry Pi am Start.
Passt eigentlich alles.
Müssten wir sonst noch irgendwas machen?
Lass mal in unser To Do gucken.
Raspberry Pi flashen.
So jetzt müssen wir in Access Point Factory defaulten.
Ich nehme den Pi Hall als Beispiel.
Wie kann ich das gewährleisten dass der ganze Traffic über den Pi läuft?
Brauche ich da eventuell zwei Netzwerkkarten?
Also wie gesagt
das mit dem Pi Hall das ist ja DNS.
Das hat ja an sich mit Netzwerk sonst nichts zu tun.
Also was du machen musst
um zu gewährleisten dass dein
Traffic durch den Raspberry Pi läuft
ist
Ja zwei Netzwerkkarten
ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Du musst dein Raspberry Pi als
Gateway verwenden.
Du stöpselst dein Raspberry Pi
an den Switch wo alle deine
anderen Rechner dranhängen.
Und benutzt den als Gateway.
Und im Prinzip auf der
anderen Seite routet dann dein Traffic raus
zum nächsten Hop.
Du musst dein Raspberry Pi als Gateway verwenden.
Das hat nichts aber auch gar nichts
mit DNS zu tun.
Das ist Netzwerkeinstellung weit unterhalb von DNS.
Du musst
den Raspberry Pi als dein Gateway einstellen.
So was du dann aber auch
nicht hinbekommen
wirst ist
dass Traffic innerhalb des gleichen
Netzes im also quasi
ok
Try I O Leute
Try I O
So Router
Neues Bild
So also
Wo ist ein schöner ist der?
Router. Das ist das offizielle Cisco Bild für Router
by the way.
Das ist dein Raspberry Pi.
Ähm
So dann haben wir noch ein Switch.
Gibt kein schönes Switch Bild.
Wie war Cisco das Bild von einem Switch nochmal?
So
So ne?
Das ist das Cisco Switch Bild.
Ich möchte das
Wie kann ich das denn
resizen ohne das die
Na wurscht.
Also das hier ist der Router
und das hier ist sagen wir mal ein 24 Port
Port Switch
So und hier hast du deine PCs dran.
Kann Pi Hall auch Netzwerk
Firewall? Ne. Dafür ist es
nicht gedacht. So und hier hast du dein Desktop
deine Desktop PCs dran.
So.
Blub. Blub.
Blub.
So. Und hier geht's dann weiter.
Zu deinem Provider.
Diese Heizung da ist dein Provider Modem.
So. Was jetzt passiert
ist, dein Raspberry Pi muss das
routen. Das hier ist der Default Gateway.
Den hier musst du als Default Gateway
angeben. Also quasi von
dem internen Interface
ähm
Also das interne Interface hat dann beispielsweise
192.168
äh 70.1
oder so
Das ist das interne Interface
und das hier ist dann dein externes Interface.
Kann was auch immer.
Ist wurscht. Irgendwas zu deinem Modem.
Ja. Keine Ahnung.
10.1.1.1
Das ist aber egal.
In dem Fall.
So. So würde das ganze dann aussehen.
Und die Dinger hier brauchen als Gateway
diese IP.
Das wird dir aber auch noch nicht alles bringen.
Weil. So.
Gateway. Ups.
So. Das müssen die
als Gateway verwenden. Die rechten
Rechner hier unten.
Und dann werden sie alles
was nicht im gleichen Netz ist
an den
an den Router schicken. Und er schickt das weiter.
Was du damit
nicht erreicht ist. Wenn
dieser Rechner
zu diesem Rechner
kommunizieren will.
Weil. Das ist im gleichen Netz.
Das geht nicht über den Router.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus.
Der hier hat irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung.
70.
70.200 oder so.
Als IP.
Ja.
Und der hat.
70.201 als IP.
Dann passiert folgendes.
Wenn der Rechner.
Wenn der hier mit dem Rechner reden will.
Dann macht der hier ein Up Request.
Ins Netzwerk. Quasi ein Broadcast.
Wo er fragt. Sag mal.
Was ist denn die MAC Adresse.
Passend zu
192.168.70.1
Und das ist wenn man.
Wenn man TCP da macht.
Who has.
So und dann antwortet der hier drauf.
Mit seiner MAC Adresse.
Und dann kann der hier das direkt an den adressieren.
Das heißt es geht in diesem Switch Port rein.
Und in diesem Switch Port raus.
Sofern der Switch diesen Rechner schon einmal gesehen hat.
Ansonsten geht es erstmal an alle raus.
Weil der Switch ja selbst noch lernen muss.
Welche MAC Adresse.
Welche MAC Adresse sind.
Hinter welchen Port sind.
Also direkte Kommunikation.
Zwischen diesen beiden.
Rechnern.
Bekommst du so.
Ohne weiteres nie.
Über ein.
Zwischen Hop.
Weil es gibt kein Hop in dem Sinn.
Und da kann man jetzt auch so einfach.
Nichts dran ändern.
Das ist so wie das Netzwerk technisch halt.
Funktioniert.
Wie kann man denn die Dicke hier machen.
So.
Also da kannst du nichts dran ändern.
Aber sobald du deinen Router als Gateway verwendest.
Dann wird alles was aus diesem Netz raus will.
Woanders hin.
Zwangsläufig über den Router geschickt.
Und dieser Router kann ein Raspberry Pi sein.
Oder irgendwas anderes.
So ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr wer das gefragt hat.
Aber.
Ja.
Kann man auch machen.
Wobei es selbst da nicht unbedingt was bringt.
WLAN technisch.
Ist das.
Das hier.
Das ist zwar kein WLAN mit WLAN Tags.
Aber im Prinzip macht ein WLAN was ähnliches.
Nur das du quasi mit einem WLAN diesen Switch.
Nochmal in zwei logische Switches.
Wenn du so willst unterteilen könntest.
Und natürlich kannst du Junk Post machen.
Zwischen zwei verschiedenen Switches.
Also das würde an der Sache nichts ändern.
Das Leute.
Also das Rechnern die im gleichen WLAN sind.
Und im gleichen Netz.
Die können miteinander interagieren.
Ohne das sie über den Router gehen müssen.
Also an der Kommunikation.
Das diese Kommunikation nicht über den Router geht.
Kannst du eigentlich nichts ändern.
So ist das.
Von der Technik her halt nun mal nicht gedacht.
Du musst nicht über einen Zwischenhop gehen.
Solange du im gleichen Netz bist.
Ja wir können tatsächlich etwas weniger einschläfern.
Dann muss ich mal.
Nein.
Das hatten wir auch schon oft.
Mario Kart.
Mir geht es nur darum.
Das alle Clients nur über Pi-Hole ins Internet gelangen.
Also.
Ob da jetzt Pi-Hole die richtige Wahl für ist.
Das als Router hinzustellen.
Sei mal in Frage gestellt.
Oder sei mal dahin gestellt.
Aber.
Das könntest du so regeln.
Möchtest du vielleicht.
Sicherstellen.
Nicht das die wirklich da drüber gehen.
Sondern das alle deinen DNS Server verwenden.
Ist das vielleicht eher das was du willst.
Willst du das alle Pi-Hole als DNS Server verwenden.
Dann musst du nämlich.
Einfach nur in deinem DHCP Server einstellen.
Das das als DNS verwendet werden soll.
Also wenn du einfach nur willst.
Das alle Leute bei dir im Netz.
Pi-Hole als DNS verwenden.
Dann.
Musst du in deinem DHCP Server einstellen.
DNS Server die IP vom Pi-Hole.
Fertig mehr nicht.
Dann können die Clients zwar immer noch.
Verwenden was sie wollen.
Als DNS Server.
Aber standardmäßig verwenden sie Pi-Hole.
Ja.
Genau.
Alternativ kannst du nämlich einfach alles andere blocken.
Auf Port 53.
Oder TCP 53 ja mittlerweile auch.
Oder das Pi-Hole als DNS verwenden.
Kannst DHCP verwenden.
Das kannst du auch machen.
Aber so sieht es aus.
Siehst du.
Deswegen ist es immer wichtig.
Dass man genauer klärt.
Was denn die Leute eigentlich wollen.
Weil das manchmal gar nicht so das ist.
Was man auf den ersten Blick versteht.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben.
Access Point resetten.
Factory default Access Point.
Wenn wir downcraten Country unlocken.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Also.
Weiter geht es.
Gut.
Dann widmen wir uns mal unserem Access Point.
Nämlich dem Teil hier.
Also wir müssen ihn jetzt resetten.
Gut.
Wo habe ich meinen Access Point.
Ja.
Den Access Point resettet man übrigens.
Da ist hinten.
Am Access Point ist ein.
Irgendwo.
Ist ein Knopf zum resetten.
Das seht ihr jetzt nicht.
Das mache ich jetzt einfach.
Und gut ist.
Und dann leuchtet er rot nachdem er resettet wurde.
Und.
Ja dann resettet er sich halt.
Was soll ich da noch groß zu sagen.
Reset.
Ich glaube zwölf Sekunden oder so.
Eins.
Zwei.
Drei.
Vier.
Fünf.
Sechs.
Sieben.
Acht.
Neun.
Zehn.
Elf.
Zwölf.
Dreizehn.
Vierzehn.
Und in der Öffentlichkeit.
Neun.
So.
Und deshalb.
Um es erstmals einfach auf Rugby zu tun auf Configure.
Weil.
Hab ich aber nicht
Wahrscheinlich, weil der noch nicht fertig gebootet ist, vermute ich mal
Ne, hab ich noch nicht
Ich
Wieso machst du das nicht über SHSH?
Ja, es gibt doch nichts, worauf man sich per SHSH verbinden kann
So, Configure me
Configure me, gut
Also, dann gehen wir jetzt mal zum Raspberry Pi
Unseren Raspberry Config
Und wir verbinden uns zum Access Point
Ähm
System Options
Wireless
Äh
Moment
Ne, wo stellt man das nochmal ein?
Hallo?
Germany?
Okay, SSID, also
Con
Figure
Punkt me
Minus
Drei, sieben
Hab ich das jetzt richtig geschrieben?
Ich hoffe mal
Passphrase gibt es nicht
Finish
League, Monkeys, Reboot
Warum soll ich rebooten?
Ja gut, meinetwegen reboot, okay
Warum muss der rebooten, um das WLAN zu aktivieren?
Ach, der muss rebooten, weil er die Länderkennung irgendwie ändern muss vom WLAN, glaube
Ich hab keine IP
Das Ding hat sein Config WLAN offen
Ich hab das gerade, gerade resettet
Vielleicht wird es eine IP bekommen
Wenn ich es an DHCP intern
Aber wir machen das mal nach ihrer Anleitung
Nach ihrer Anleitung
Also
Ich hab mich jetzt zu diesem Configure.me WLAN verbunden
So, da sind wir wieder
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert
If Config
Guck mal da
Zehn, zwei und fünf
Was zum
Das scheint mein Gateway zu sein
Okay, also wie geht's weiter?
Wir verbinden uns zu Configure.me
Und dann
Depending on your browser
You may be presented with a security warning
Bla bla bla bla
Äh, ne
Ach, ne
Ach, Moment, ich muss das mit nem Browser machen
Okay, Zeit für SSH-Forwarding
Äh, apt install file
Oder Chrome
Chrome, yum
Browser
Das mag ich ja an Raspberry Pi, dass sie den, den, an, an dem Raspberry Pi
Boah, alter
Ja, komm, gib ihm
Dass, ähm, die nicht Snaps ausliefern, sondern noch richtig echte Packages
Also, wer denkt, npm install install?
Also, wer denkt, npm install install, install
ist gut
Ja, 분들은
minus Y. So.
PassWD. Ich vergebe jetzt ein super
krass geheimes Passwort.
Okay.
Perfekt. Bestes Passwort.
Das wollte ich schon immer machen. Achso, Current Passwort.
Lul. So. Beste.
Okay. Und jetzt
starten wir mal Chromium Browser.
Und dann schauen wir mal, ob das hier
funktioniert, was die da schreiben.
Wir sollen... Also wir sind connected.
Sekunden, Leute. Ich mach nochmal kurz
aus.
Äh. T-Max auf.
Also. Wir sind connected mit
dem Access Point
Configure WLAN.
Und jetzt sollen wir angeblich
da auf diese IP gehen.
Unleashed.
Löst das Ding überhaupt auf? Da bin ich jetzt mal
sehr gespannt. Ruggus
Wireless.com
Nö.
Natürlich nicht. Okay. Jetzt machen wir
Trick 17, Leute.
Massive. Massive Trick.
Gucken, ob das tut.
Ähm. Wir sind verbunden mit dem
Access Point. Und der Access Point
hat diese IP.
Geh ich mal ganz stark von aus.
Weil die hier hab ich. Und das ist die
andere, die es gibt. Das ist der Access Point.
Und...
Wo waren wir denn jetzt?
Host Eintrag. Genau.
Das... Das... Was?
Kein WIM installiert. Cringe,
wer kein WIM installiert hat, Alter.
Richtig cringe.
ETC
Hosts.
Ähm.
Ruggus.
Was da?
Äh. Allerdings. Sekunde.
Auf diese IP.
Bin mal gespannt, ob das jetzt klappt, was ich mir da
überlegt hab.
Okay. Chrome. Browser.
Emacs.
Ja, ganz bestimmt zerleg ich mir jetzt einen Emacs für.
So. Gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Und Postchamp. Postchamp.
Hey. Your connection is not private.
Oh mein Gott.
My connection is not private.
Fuck.
Okay. Also.
Unleashed Installation.
Nein. Wir wollen ein lokales Upgrade machen.
From a local image.
Weil ich muss downgraden.
Damit ich, äh, die, äh, den Country-Unlock machen kann. Okay.
R600. Leute, ich zieh den Access Point nochmal ab.
Ich hab keinen Bock, dass die ganze Zeit so lange ein offenes WLAN am Start ist.
Äh. R600. Download.
Firmware Download.
Unleashed. Unleashed. Oh no.
Also wir brauchen nämlich eine Firmware.
Und jetzt kommt der Knackpunkt. Also.
Ich hab einen Access Point gekauft,
der, ähm,
für die USA gemacht ist.
Damit man den in, in Deutschland
betreiben darf,
muss man ihn auf Deutsch umstellen.
Ja, weil wir unterschiedliche
Reglementierungen haben, was Sendeleistung
angeht, äh, Channels, Frequenzen,
was auch immer.
Standardmäßig geht das nicht. Wenn du's
versuchst standardmäßig, äh, zu ändern,
dann bekommt man als Antwort,
ähm, illegal
to change country code. Deswegen
gibt es einen Trick, wie man den
Access Point umstellen kann.
Oder besser gesagt, wie man den, im Prinzip
gibt es für Access Points plus zwei Regionen.
USA oder nicht-USA.
Nicht-USA
kann alle anderen Länder auswählen.
USA kann nur USA.
So. Und
mein Access Point ist leider etwas
älter, den ich hier hab.
Er ist pre-2020,
weil wie gesagt, heute testen wir's ja mit dem Alten.
Und
deswegen brauche ich, muss ich eine, muss
ich ein Firmware-Downgrade
durchführen, damit ich mir
eine Rootshell besorgen kann über eine
Sicherheitslücke auf dem Access Point.
Und wenn ich die Rootshell habe
auf dem Access Point, dann kann ich mein Country
Unlock machen, und danach
kann ich auch upgraden auf eine Firmware,
die die Sicherheitslücke nicht mehr hat.
Also
richtige Hackermans, Hackermans-Zeug
und so weiter.
Soweit verstanden, Chat?
Ist das soweit klar?
Also ich muss jetzt erstmal die Firmware downgraden.
Auf ein Release vor November 2019.
So.
Hier.
Unleashed vor 2000...
Ich brauch ein Unleashed...
Moment, was schreiben die?
Ich brauch ein Unleashed
vor November
2019.
Unleashed
2020.
In welcher Farbe der Access Point ist?
Hier, so. So cremefarbenweiß.
So. Unleashed vor
2019.
2018?
2019? Vor November
2019 hat er gesagt.
Also das hier ist wahrscheinlich die Firmware, mit der
sie das gefixt haben, die Sicherheitslücke.
Das heißt, wir brauchen
eine Firmware, die
älter ist. Also
die da zum Beispiel.
Filename, Download, ja.
Okay. Oh, come on!
Please!
No!
Seriously, zum Downloaden von der Firmware
muss ich mich registrieren.
No! Na gut.
10-Minute-Mail.
Ja, genau.
So wollte ich schon immer mal heißen.
Ich hab
kein Account, jaja.
Firstname kek, Lastname
w, E-Mail,
Passwort.
Ja genau, das nehme ich jetzt auch gerade, dass ich dann hier
wieder damit einloggen kann, hier.
So.
Jaja, wir accepten alles.
SEG I
Register.
Ja, save mal. Wer weiß, ob ich das
nicht nochmal brauche.
Thank you. Darf ich denn downloaden
vielleicht jetzt schon?
Darf ich vielleicht so schon downloaden?
Ohne? Ist das vielleicht
erlaubt? Jaja, genau.
Login.
Okay.
Ich darf warten, dass ich die Firmware runterladen kann,
bis ich eine Bestätigungs-E-Mail bekommen habe.
Das ist doch lächerlich, Alter.
Nee, das muss so funktionieren.
Ich brauche keinen Link.
Haha! Thank you.
In order to complete
the process,
click the link below.
Ah ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Dear kek.
Ah, guck mal, jetzt downloadet er auch.
Okay, nice. Kann ich das vielleicht
jetzt so downloaden?
Direkt vom Raspberry Pi?
Gilt der Download-Link
vielleicht noch jetzt?
Seid mal so nett.
Hey! Meine Session,
meine Session gilt noch.
Leute, ihr könnt jetzt alle meine krasse
Session hijacken hiermit.
So.
Also.
Zum Download ist Curl besser.
Okay, da haben wir's.
MV, wir
benennen das mal kurz um.
Äh, in das da.
Weil ansonsten erkennt das wahrscheinlich
am Ende nicht mehr.
Okay, wunderbar.
Also, Browser, Browser.
Downcranen.
Ah, nee.
Haha, nicht, nicht downcranen.
Ich, äh, muss den Access Point erst wieder
einschalten.
Ich muss den Access Point erst wieder einschalten.
So.
Wo ist hier meine Anleitung dazu,
wie das funktioniert?
Alles klar.
Hm.
Noch ist er nicht da.
Hoffentlich behält er auch seine IP.
Und randomize die nicht oder so.
Achso, ja, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich
hier? Bin ich noch im...
Ah, guck mal, mein WLAN hat sich disconnected.
Aber der Raspberry Pi sollte erkennen, wenn das
WLAN wieder oben ist und sich wieder neu
connect champen.
Irgendwann.
Ich guck mal auf mein Handy, ob das Teil wieder da ist.
Nope.
Ah ja, jetzt ist er wieder da.
Raspberry Pi,
connect please.
Connect please, connect please.
Muss ich jetzt rebooten, dass der sich
wieder connectet? Nee, oder?
Der sollte sich doch auch alleine wieder
connecten.
Das ist
ein R600, das ist hier für den Stream
zum ausprobieren. Okay, anscheinend
nicht. Äh, benutzen werde ich
dann ein R710.
Configure
me
minus
37DC40
finish. Raspberry
Pi, please. Kann man
dem irgendwie sagen reconnecten?
Wie kann ich dem sagen reconnecten?
Das ist doch nicht euer Ernst, dass ich rebooten
muss jetzt, oder?
Meine Güte.
Die Dinger reconnecten sich doch immer
automatisch.
Ich mein, ich hab'n Raspberry Pi
im Keller stehen, äh,
im Erdgeschoss stehen, am 3D Drucker
und selbst wenn ich meine Access Points gebe, die Dinger
reconnecten sich immer automatisch.
Ach, kein Plan. Wir rebooten
einfach. Reboot geht immer.
Reboot champ. Ifconfig?
Hallo.
Please connecten.
Aha.
A minus N. Der hat auch die gleiche
IP. Okay, wir können weitermachen.
Chrome.
Okay. Also wir downgraden
jetzt. Wir downgraden jetzt
die Firmware. Das heißt,
wir gehen jetzt dahin. Zack.
Gehen auf die Adresse.
Für irgendwelche Gründe nicht mal
funktionieren.
Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder?
Hat er doch gecheckt?
Er hat's doch kapiert, dass es die Adresse
nicht gibt. HTTPS.
Ja, Browser?
Was ist das Problem?
Browser. Hallo.
Okay, was auch immer.
Hä?
Moment.
Ist die IP falsch?
Schauen wir mal. Also das
ist die IP. Hosts.
So, richtig.
So.
Ich installiere so ein Firefox zusätzlich,
wenn Chrome nicht will.
Ja, es heißt Firefox
ESR.
Das ist das einfachste von der Welt.
Wenn ein fucking Browser auf eine
Uhr geht.
Das muss doch funktionieren.
Auf Firefox. Mach hin.
So, dann machen wir Firmware Downgrade.
Wenn wir Firmware Downgrade gemacht haben,
loggen wir uns dort per SSH ein.
Und...
Jo.
Das war's.
Dann probieren wir das aus.
Okay, Ping tut er.
Das ist doch schon mal ganz gut. Firefox.
Was? Achso, ich bin
root. Daran liegt das. Ja, logisch.
Firefox.
Nee, die haben keine komische
Lizenz, nur wenn du den in ihren Controller
schalten willst. Oh, komm. Firefox, please.
Keine Animation.
Das ist X-Forwarding über SSH.
Kann ich Animationen jetzt wirklich nicht gebrauchen.
Geh mal weg. Flexgrill.
Ich brauch keine Animationen
jetzt. Komm, Firefox.
Please. Ich mach gleich den
SOX-Proxy und mach das mit meinem Browser
lokal. Was ist denn das
hier?
Okay. Schließt.
Ich kann das Fenster
nicht mal beenden. Bam.
So.
Da geht's jetzt vielleicht mit dem Chrome.
Jetzt funktioniert's. Okay.
Was auch immer.
Komm, geh doch mal auf.
Jetzt ist doch alles gut. Gut.
Excellent. Okay.
Firmware upgrade, beziehungsweise Firmware
downgrade. Upgrade ist
an Licht-RP vom Local Image.
Next.
Ähm...
Ja.
Nein.
Es gibt wenig Sinn, was da
steht, aber okay.
So. Firmware upgrade,
beziehungsweise Downgrade.
Warum kein UniFi?
Weil mir Features fehlen und ich auch allgemein
nicht glücklich bin mit meinen UniFi-Dingern.
Das ist jetzt nur zum... Also ich hab
mir zwei gekauft. Ich hab mir einen
R600 gekauft und zum
rumspielen und ausprobieren. Weil ich
noch nie was mit diesen Access Points gemacht habe.
Und...
Mit...
Einen R710,
das ist quasi das Vorgängermodell vom aktuellen
Kostet aber auch nur ein Achtel auf Ebay.
Dann zum benutzen
hier. So.
Firmware downgrade.
Local upgrading will take few minutes.
Yes.
Server Java
Pages. Ah ja, das ist eine Firmware von sonst
wann. Ist mir egal, was das
benutzt, ob das funktioniert.
Now upgrading.
Er upgradet. Was macht
er? Er blinkt komisch.
Ähm... Der ist überhaupt nicht erreichbar,
der Access Point gerade, oder?
Schauen wir mal.
Doch, er ist noch erreichbar.
Alles gut.
Jetzt hat er rebooted.
Guckt mal, jetzt hat er rebooted.
Jetzt ist er nicht mehr
erreichbar. Was hast du
für den R710 gezahlt? Äh...
260,
70 Euro
in dem Dreh. 270 Euro.
Ziemlich, ziemlich...
Ich weiß es nicht auf Cent genau, aber ziemlich, ziemlich
genau 270 Euro. Wir können da mal kurz
nebenbei just for fun gucken, was es auf Ebay gibt.
Was es gerade so kostet.
Rogus!
Schauen wir mal, was zuletzt eingestellt wurde.
Äh... Bestergebnisse...
Äh...
Neu eingestellt.
Also 500er würde ich nicht kaufen.
Ist quasi zu alt, auch end of life
und gibt keine Firmware mehr.
Entweder R610 oder R710
oder meinetwegen auch R510,
aber noch irgendwas, was halbwegs aktuelle Firmware bekommt.
Besser natürlich sogar.
Ja, sowas könnte man sich zum Beispiel holen, aber
wie gesagt, ganz schön teuer.
Ähm...
So, aber
Chat, nachdem...
Ganz bestimmt. Ähm...
Aber, nachdem ihr ja gesehen habt, dass der
Country-Unlock funktioniert,
gucken wir doch mal hier.
Weil bei den Amis die Dinger sind billig.
Ist ja, bei den Amis kriegst du die teilweise schon...
Na, okay.
Letzte Woche hatten wir doch was für 240 Dollar.
Ist teurer geworden.
Ich will das Unified Zeug loswerden.
Ja, also bei den Amis hast du wahrscheinlich
noch ganz gute Chancen.
Was zu bekommen.
Alter, diese Preise, man.
So, hat er jetzt upgradet?
Hat er es jetzt geschafft endlich?
Ne, der blinkt immer noch wie verrückt.
Okay.
So, er ist aber angeblich wieder oben.
Aber pingen tut er nicht.
Er pinkt wahrscheinlich nicht, weil sich
mein Raspberry Pi wieder disconnected.
Warum disconnected sich mein Raspberry Pi?
Der kostet 1,4k.
Das ist aber ein bescheuerter Preis.
Selbst der aktuelle kostet weniger.
Was?
Sag mal,
wer muss das Ding doch force reconnecten
können über Kommandozeile?
Aha, das da habe ich gesucht.
Das habe ich gesucht.
So, da hat sich nicht
reconnected WLAN technisch.
Das heißt,
schauen wir mal.
So, den Browser machen wir mal zu.
Können wir gleich wieder öffnen.
Da steht es ja, man soll ihn nicht schließen.
Aber ich meine, who cares, was da steht.
So, Reconfigure.
Du darfst dich jetzt
please neu connecten.
Raspberry Pi, es ist erlaubt,
dass du dich neu connectest.
Der Access Point steht
10cm von dir weg.
Sag nicht, dass du den nicht sehen kannst.
Oder er ist
mit dem Upgrade noch nicht fertig.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Was sagen denn meine LEDs?
Meine LEDs sagen, dass
Power und Deer blinkt.
Heißt das, der updatet jetzt noch?
Kannst du das WLAN...
Ja, ich sehe das WLAN noch am Handy.
Ich kann mal gucken, ob ich mich connecten kann.
Ach, wobei, scheiß drauf.
Das wird schon gleich funktionieren.
Wisst ihr, was ich reboote jetzt?
Schade auch nichts.
Connecten wir uns mal.
Connect Champ.
Auf.
Der hat keinen Bock sich zu connecten.
Der denkt sich, nope,
no pass.
Wait a minute.
Das da ist aber nicht die richtige IP.
Das ist diese IP, die WLANs
bekommen, wenn sie keine
IP bekommen. Das ist diese
Autoconfig-Geschichte.
EW-Config.
SSID.
Configure me. Ist doch gut so.
Alter, das macht mich fertig.
Warum kann der sich nicht
einfach verbinden?
Ich guck mal, ob ich da mit dem Handy drauf komme.
Ja, mit dem Handy komme ich.
Da.
Mit dem Handy komme ich drauf.
Und?
Ich kriege auch eine richtige IP.
Keine Ahnung.
Warum sind einfache
Sachen teilweise so schwer?
Was soll das?
Ok.
Respy-Config.
EW-Config. Ich mach das jetzt einfach nochmal.
System.
Wireless. Jawoll.
Yes.
Finish.
Force-Champ. Force-Champ.
Alter, Raspberry Pi,
was ist denn jetzt dein Problem, Mann?
Was ist
hier das?
Warum geht das nicht?
Warum connectest du dich nicht? Ich kann mich doch mit meinem Handy auch connecten.
Von welcher Marke?
Das ist der hier. So, jetzt im Stream gerade
ist es der hier.
Verwenden wir echt ein R710.
Ja, sag mal.
Will mich das Ding veräppeln?
Also der Access-Point muss mittlerweile
fertig sein mit dem Upgrade.
Ich ziehe jetzt den Access-Point gleich
raus und
reboote den nochmal.
Ich meine,
das Update läuft jetzt schon 3 Minuten oder so
oder 10 Minuten oder lange.
Warum eigentlich F-Config
nicht EW-Config? Weil ich wissen will, ob ich eine
IP bekommen habe oder nicht.
Ja, du hast das richtig gegoogelt, aber
deswegen kauft man die sich auch gebraucht auf Ebay.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung,
was er für Schmerzen hat hier.
So, ich reboote jetzt mal beides.
Ich reboote den
Access-Point.
Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt nicht gebrickt,
weil ich ihn während dem Update ausgeschaltet habe.
Und ich reboote den
Raspberry Pi auch.
Sobald das WLAN da ist.
Was ist denn an dem Ding so krass?
Gut, das hier ist ja die vorvorletzte
Generation. Die würde ich mir jetzt nicht unbedingt noch
kaufen. Wie gesagt, aber ich werde dann den
R710 verwenden, weil er richtig gut ist.
Er hat so coole Features, wie zum Beispiel,
dass du jedem Gerät ein extra Passwort
geben kannst. Auch Geräten, die
keinen WPA Enterprise unterstützen.
Was gerade für IoT-Geräte
so ein richtig hypernices Feature
ist. Ein
POG-Feature.
Access-Point, starte
dich neu.
Ok, Configami ist da.
Raspberry Pi
rebooten. Wenn das jetzt nicht geht, dann
raste dich aus.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Weil wenn es lädt,
dann stürzt es ab, oder so.
Auf.
Das ist eigentlich das, was am einfachsten
gehen soll. Sollte.
Sich einfach mit dem Raspberry Pi
auf Nexus Point verbinden. Mann, so schwer
kann es doch nicht sein.
Der connectet sich nicht.
Warum?
Warum connectest du dich nicht?
Raspberry Pi, was soll das?
Die Anzeige ist
10-fach raus schon.
Warum connectest du dich nicht?
Da dran, Quatsch.
Das hat doch vorher auch funktioniert.
Wenn es lädt, kannst du es nicht flashen.
Das ist richtig.
Wo ist das?
WPA-Supplikant.
Ich lösche jetzt die
WiFi-Config.
Bam.
Ok.
Raspberry-Config.
Wireless LAN.
Configami. Heißt das Ding
wenigstens noch so?
Kontrolle.
Configami
37DC40.
Jo. Kein Passwort.
Finish.
Nein, das ist nicht
pricked. Ich sehe es mit dem Handy und kann
mich mit dem Handy connecten. Aber warum
connectet sich mein Raspberry Pi nicht? Was ist das?
Ja, die
SSID ist noch die gleiche.
Was zum Teufel ist
das für eine Kacke?
Nochmal Reboot.
Leute, ich kann doch nicht
Rebooten das Ding.
Ok.
config
ure
.mi
minus
37DC40
Genau so.
Warum connectet sich der Kram nicht?
Was ist das?
Ich
checke es nicht.
Ich kann es jetzt mit dem Handy machen, aber ich will, dass ihr das seht.
Der
Country Code ist falsch.
Warum sollte der auf einmal falsch sein?
Der war eben noch richtig.
Tja.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nächstes Point
ist, das macht nichts.
Es hat doch vorhin auch funktioniert. Warum sollte
das jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr klappen?
Hm.
Tja, Leute.
Jetzt bin ich gerade sehr
planlos. Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Äh.
Ich resette den nächstes Point nochmal.
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt das 4x Downgrade gemacht.
Da kann ich ja resetten und dann sollte es wieder
funktionieren.
3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16. So.
Access Point resettet sich.
Das Gerät ist schon 50x
neu gestartet.
Oh. Reboot.
Also.
Das ist doch echt beknackt, Alter.
Oh.
Nein.
Das will ich nicht.
Ich will keinen IW-List machen.
So. Das Ding resettet sich jetzt.
Rebootet. Blinkt wie verrückt. Sollte gleich
wieder oben sein. Ich sehe es ja dann am Handy, wenn es da ist.
So.
Noch ist es nicht oben.
Gut. Also.
Raspi Config.
Ich tippe das jetzt gleich nochmal vom Handy ab.
Da ist es. Also.
Config.
Uhre. Uhre.
Punkt.
Mi. Minus. 3. 7.
DC. 4. 0.
Bam.
Bam. Was hat das Ding?
Warum kann ich mich WLAN-mäßig
nicht mehr connecten?
Was ist das denn?
Du hast vorhin keine Updates
beim Pi gemacht. Ist doch vollkommen egal.
Der Access Point ist auf.
Ich sehe das Ding in meinem Handy.
Und ich konnte mich vorhin direkt mit den
exakt gleichen Settings dahin zu verbinden.
Dahin verbinden. Warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr?
Was ist das denn? Kann doch nicht sein.
Ne. Der Access Point ist nicht kaputt.
Ich sehe es auf dem Handy und kann mich auf dem Handy
hin verbinden.
Aber mein Raspberry Pi hat keinen Bock da drauf.
Was absolut keinen Sinn ergibt.
Warum sollte der sich ja zweimal nicht mehr hin
verbinden können?
Lul.
Ne. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Alias Felbi willst
du machen. Alias.
Tja Leute. Ich habe ernsthaft
keinen blassen Schimmer. Warum das nicht
funktioniert. Der
muss sich doch jetzt verbinden zum Access Point Mann.
Warum macht er das denn nicht?
Und ich klicke das Setup nicht mit dem Handy
durch.
Ah ja. Da hast du recht. Da könnte man tatsächlich mal reingucken.
Gibt es nicht.
Lul weh.
Muss man bestimmt erst einschalten oder?
Syslog?
Ne. Es kann doch eigentlich
nichts sein. Ich meine es hat sich auch
außerdem. Irgendwann Downgrade auf dem
Access Point. Hat sich doch nichts getan.
Mein PC hat Wlan. Mein Handy sagt
dass es da ist. Es ist alles da Mann.
Messages?
EPA?
Log. Wie kriegt
man den Crample her?
Äh.
Minus D?
Was? Wie? Wo? Was?
Weiß ich was ihr vor mir wollt.
Wie kriege ich vor meinem Netzwerk
Interface?
Minus W ist doch vollkommen egal.
Ich habe doch da gerade schon reingeguckt.
Minus W ist nur warten
bis neues Zeug reinkommt.
How to enable logging. Ja genau.
It's complicated.
Ja das ist ja schon mal toll.
Was ist das? Alter.
Warum ist er nach dem Firmware Downgrade nicht mehr in der Lage
sich im Wlan zu verbinden?
Ich bin geneigt es einfach auf dem Handy
durchzuklicken jetzt und drauf
zu scheißen. Aber
das kann doch nicht sein.
Der muss sich doch verbinden.
Es ging doch vorhin alles.
Das kann nicht sein dass sich da irgendwie
großartig was geändert hat.
So also der Name ist auch
komplett richtig.
Hm.
Ich habe keine Ahnung wie ich das dem beibringen soll
dass der sich da jetzt verbindet.
Es regt mich schon wieder auf dass so einfache
Dinger wie Connecten zu einem Wlan nicht funktionieren.
Hm. Tja.
Irgendwas Buggy am 64
Bit.
Vielleicht.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Was zum?
Das ist ja mal eine
Fifat Ausgabe.
Was sagt denn der eigentlich?
Der sagt gar nichts.
Ja super geil.
Das wird uns nicht allzu viel bringen.
Also Logs gibt es ja aus irgendwelchen
Gründen da nicht dazu.
Ich habe keine Ahnung
wie man das dem beibringen soll noch.
Ich mein
mehr als sagen
verbinde dich mal im Wlan.
Kannst du ja nicht machen.
Aber da wird doch auch nicht mehr stehen.
Ja.
Geil. Nice.
Das was man auch bei Status gesehen hat.
POG.
Den interessiert das absolut gar nicht.
Leute.
Es ist doch scheißegal.
Das ging doch eben bis vor das Firmware Update man.
Denkt doch mal nach
bevor ihr irgendwie ultra krasses Backstreet
und alles den Blödsinn schreibt.
Das einzige
was ich gemacht, das ist ein Firmware-Downgrade
vom Access Point.
Und da wird bestimmt nicht auf einmal
von 2,4 GHz
auf 17,5 GHz
funken oder so jetzt auf einmal.
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wenn schon, also das Wahrscheinlichste, was ich mir
irgendwie erklären könnte ist,
dass also wirklich irgendwas
mit dem 64-Bit
Raspbian Pi OS
zu tun hat. Weil ansonsten
ergibt es überhaupt keinen Sinn, warum der sich nicht
zum Access Point connecten sollte. Zumal,
wenn ich mein Handy nehme
und klicke das
WLAN an,
dann geht er ins WLAN und freut
sich seines Lebens und sagt, ja gut,
kriege IP, alles gut.
Also das WLAN ist offen, daran
liegt das nicht. Das liegt einzig und
allein an dem Raspberry Pi, der aus irgendwelchen Gründen
keinen Bock hat,
sich in das WLAN zu
verbinden. Der Name ist richtig,
das Passwort ist richtig,
aber er hat keinen Bock.
Und ich weiß nicht,
warum.
Wir könnten das vom Rechner aus machen.
Ja, das könnten wir machen.
Jetzt geht's.
Ne.
Der kriegt keine IP.
Aber ihr seht, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Aber da zieht sich keine IP.
Warum nicht?
Okay, scheiß drauf, wir machen das jetzt anders.
Wir machen das, wir machen das anders.
10.
Ich hab das nämlich keinen Bock zu ewig.
10, 2, 3, 1, 1, 5, 1.
So.
Ne, 1
verschieben. 1, 2, 5.
So, das geht natürlich nicht.
Jetzt! Hat funktioniert!
Easy!
Einfach 50 mal rebooten, es funktioniert.
Alles klar, gut.
Also, könnt ihr alle euren
Kram schon mal vergessen, ihr hattet alle nicht recht.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber man muss einfach nur oft genug rebooten, dann funktioniert's.
So, easy.
Dazu kann man nur sagen,
easy as fuck.
E-e-easy as get rekt.
Easy as fuck.
Okay, jetzt funktioniert's.
Teamworks, Chrome.
Okay, und jetzt gehen wir auf
Unleashed.
Da gehen wir jetzt hin.
Und wenn er jetzt wieder nicht funktioniert
mit seiner komischen Seite, drehe ich, drehe ich ab.
Jaja, ist doch HTTPS.
No, god, please, no!
No!
WLAN as a service, ja.
Ja, IP ist richtig.
Okay, das mit dem Reconfigure
ist Blödsinn von Stack Overflow, das funktioniert nicht.
Die Musik passt gut,
jaja, finde ich auch.
Hi, reconnect, WiFi,
CLI. Nein,
if up, if down ist bescheuert.
Da gibt's was.
Ja, das funktioniert bei mir aber nicht.
Kann man vielleicht einfach sagen.
Nope, kann man nicht.
Vielleicht ist wirklich ein Problem vom 64-Bit.
Ich bin geneigt,
auf 32-Bit zu
downgraden.
So, einmal reboot ich den Kram noch, dann wird er neu geflasht.
Hab da kein F drauf.
Brauchst du lieber ifconfig?
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab mich schon jahrelang an ifconfig gewöhnt,
aber ich versuche,
immer, wenn ich mich beim ifconfig-Tipp
erwische, eigentlich IP-Ads zu machen,
aber ganz ehrlich,
eigentlich ist es wurscht.
Eigentlich ist es egal.
Du hast heutzutage eher IP
vorinstalliert als ifconfig.
Aber,
naja,
WLAN ist down.
Aha, sehr schön.
Gut zu wissen.
WLAN ist down.
Warum?
Weil,
weil, weil WLAN down ist.
Einfach.
IPA, ja, ich benötige IP-ID.
WLAN ist down.
Okay, WLAN ist down.
Weil man weiß, dass ich auch, WLAN ist, WLAN ist down.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
WLAN ist down.
Easy, easy WLAN down.
WLAN, WLAN ist einfach down.
Einfach down.
Mal gucken, ob der gleich noch startet.
WLAN, WLAN ist down.
Das ist ihm egal.
WLAN macht Bad-Gill.
Ja, hat keinen Bock.
Einfach down.
So, pass mal auf.
Wir sagen ihm jetzt einfach, sich nochmal zu connecten.
Da, bam.
Nö, wollen wir nicht.
Haben wir keinen Bock.
Gleich mit 433 MHz Versuch, ja.
Über LoRa funken am besten.
Oh, guck mal.
WLAN ist jetzt ab, oder?
Hups.
Finish.
Nein.
WLAN ist nicht ab.
Okay, Leute.
Ich flashe den Raspberry Pi jetzt.
Ist mir egal.
Ich flashe den jetzt mit 32-Bit.
Das ist mir zu blöd.
Access Point aus.
So.
Kann nicht sein.
Das einfachste von der Welt funktioniert wieder nicht.
Was ist hier los?
Triple Anzeige, Alter.
So.
Wo habe ich meinen?
Hier.
Flashen.
Flashen 32-Bit.
Egal.
Bam.
So.
Immer wieder.
Imager.
Zack.
Choose OS.
OSA.
Light 32-Bit.
Choose Storage.
2TB.
Bla.
Ja, ja.
Alles gut hier.
PIE.
F.
White.
Yes.
Arch Arm.
Da kann ich auch Arch, by the way, haben auf meinem Raspberry PIE.
Das ist gut.
Kann ich der Welt mitteilen, dass ich Arch verwende auch wenns um Raspberry PIE ist.
So.
Auch wenn es um Raspberry Pis geht.
Das sollten wir unbedingt mal machen.
By the way.
Einzig wahre Betriebssystem.
Yes. Continue.
Continue. Sudo. Minus I.
Ich bin mal...
Mount. Also was hat das denn gemountet?
SDB. Mount.
MNT.
Touch.
SSH. Zack. U-Mount.
MNT. Sync.
So. Ab.
Und...
Ran an den Raspberry Pi.
USB.
Stecker. Switch.
Blub. Einstöpseln.
Gut.
IP sollte gleich bleiben.
Weil...
Ich hab vorhin
Static Reservierung im DHCP gemacht.
Ich lass den Access Point
noch aus. Bis der
Raspberry Pi hochgefahren ist
und alles funktioniert.
Ich dreh durch, Alter.
Warum ist so einfacher
Krempeln immer so brutalst schwer?
Nächstes Mal
nehm ich mir einen WLAN USB Stick
und schleif den durch an meine
VM und mach das von der VM.
Ich mein, wer konnte davon ausgehen,
dass es mit dem Raspberry Pi ein Ding der
Unmöglichkeit ist,
sich in den WLAN zu verbinden?
Hätte man jetzt nicht mit gerechnet
eigentlich, oder?
Chat sagt auch in der letzten Zeit, dass es
ein Gefühl hat, dass die einfachsten
Sachen immer broken sind.
Ja, echt so.
True.
Lulwe.
HDX.
Auf Raspberry Pi. Gib ihm.
Gute.
Also die SSD-Aktivitätsleuchte
ist wie verrückt am Plinken.
Eingestöpselt ist er auch.
Angeblich hab ich da WIM auf.
Was? Achso.
Ah, da ist er wieder.
SSH. Bam. Ach ja, minus
R. Erstmal löschen.
Jetzt. Yes.
Raspberry.
Jawoll.
Äh.
SSH.
Copy ID.
Sehr schön.
S.
Äh.
Ja.
Fast WD.
Raspberry.
So, Dominus I.
Update.
Ich mein, jetzt haben wir 32-Bit.
Ich mach den Access Point schon mal wieder an.
Wenn es jetzt nicht funktioniert,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ähm.
Up. Install.
T-Max. Chromium.
Großer.
Brauchen wir alles.
Wir optimizen das jetzt.
Ich muss eh rebooten für die WLAN-Settings.
Für die Länder-WLAN-Settings.
Und.
Da mach ich jetzt gerade noch ein Kernel-Update schnell.
Auf dem Ding.
Und dann sollte der Access Point auch oben sein.
Ja, ja. Ich mach auch noch ein Upgrade.
Auf. Gib ihm.
Volle Pulle.
Sag mal, ist mein Raspberry Pi am verrecken gerade?
Ich mein, das ist ernst.
Ihr habt doch eben gesehen.
Eben ging das doch dreimal so schnell.
Was hat der jetzt auf einmal für Probleme?
Das ist doch definitiv nicht normal.
Ist halt nur 32.
Ja, aber das hat doch keine Geschwindigkeitsunterschiede in diesem Ausmaß.
Gut, ich mein, wir können das ja mal parallel machen.
Aber was ist das da oben schon wieder?
RGB.
RGB, ja stimmt.
Daran könnte es liegen.
Vielleicht sollte ich noch RGB einschalten.
Okay.
Tragen wir den Krempel schon mal ein.
Also.
System.
Wireless.
Germany.
Ah, nee.
Yes.
Konfigure.me
Minus.
3 7 DC 4 0.
Keine SSID.
Yes.
Reboot.
Äh.
Scheiß drauf.
Keck wait.
Yes.
Rebooten wir einfach während dem Update.
Das wird schon, wird schon gut werden, ja.
Wird schon, wird schon alles funktionieren.
Noch ist er angeblich da.
Jetzt ist er nicht mehr da.
Doch er ist immer noch da.
Warum ist er immer noch da?
Aber Connection refused.
Kann das sein, dass der irgendwie rumschmackt, weil ich ihn rebooted hab, während er Updates gemacht hat?
Ne, der hat ein ganz gutes Case.
Der wird nicht throttlen.
Der wird irgendwelche andere machen.
Der wird irgendwelche andere Probleme haben.
Gut.
Leute.
Geht nicht anders.
Strom raus.
Strom rein.
Und dann hoffen, dass noch alles funktioniert.
Geht der Boot noch?
Okay, er leuchtet.
Grün.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Grüne Lampe geht aus und blinkt jetzt gleich hoffentlich.
Ja, ja.
Sieht gut aus.
Okay, okay.
Er sollte booten.
Ich muss ja noch ein Upgrade machen.
Vielleicht verbindet er sich jetzt aber auch WLAN-technisch.
Okay.
Auf Reset.
aufmachen das kann doch nicht sein dass du die einfachsten dinge nicht funktionieren heute ich
mache da gleich eine micro sd karte rein und dann ist ruhe wenn er mit ssd so rumspackt ich flash
schon mal eine micro sd karte ist mir echt jetzt gab es echt kein nerv drauf ich mache den export
noch mal aus ich flashe jetzt eine micro sd karte 32g micro sd karte gar kein bock mehr auf den
scheiß jetzt normalerweise sollte das mit ssd deutlich zuverlässiger sein aber gut wenn er
nicht will wenn er nicht will dann kriegt er halt nein du sollst nicht dahin du sollst na gehst
sofort er ist wirklich ja verreckt jetzt kek wait alter was ist das so pi imager choose os wir nehmen
wieder 32g micro sd karte
32 bit 32 bit light naja 32 bit light storage 32g ssd right was was would you like to apply
image customization settings saved earlier ja ist doch gut yes okay lass mich ran der
raspberry pi ist nicht mehr gebootet in der zwischenzeit weihnachts snoop
singt
zurück okay ssd pass mal auf was hast du mit der ssd jetzt machen auf mit der ssd machen wir jetzt
den scheiß kack dinger das kann auch nicht sein dass das beim noten dass er sich einfach ja ich
habe keine ssd gegen die macht geschwitzt aber es sollte ja wahrscheinlich nichts passiert sein
läuft
so da ist deshalb nicht ja trotzdem pakai ich war ganz энергiefrei also ich habe noch einen
Whoa oh das hat er mal gemacht
also wir sich Electric Helm
gut
warte
absorbiert
Entschuldigung
Okay
es geht
gleich
an
Und
f blend
Ja
wind
ist gut doch so dominos mountain mnt ssh touch ssh okay gut an mount anbauen mnt sagt so jetzt
war ich der micro sd karte rein und sie jetzt hoffentlich alter funktioniert jetzt dreht durch
dauert so was ja mal so lang ganz einfacher kram man so ist denn jetzt das netzteil
er ist an ping warten bis er oben ist
bohrmaschine ist super ich will sie ja nicht kaputt machen die ssd ist auch bestimmt nicht
kaputt gegangen vom gegen die wand schmeißen ssd sind äußerst robust robust deutlich robuster als
festplan
also magnet festplatte wäre jetzt hinüber hätte ich gegen die wand geschmissen welche
nexus point gibt es denn heute im stream zum testen gibt es den hier gekauft habe ich mir
den und in r710 in r710 werde ich verwenden und den habe ich jetzt hier zum testen und ich dachte
nicht dass wir zwei stunden leute wir sind schon über zwei stunden zu gange und haben noch nicht
mal den kram geflasht weil der raspberry pi keinen bock hat heute wie sieht es denn aus die ssd leuchte
durchgängig das ist meistens kein gutes zeichen wenn die ssd durchgängig leuchtet leute durchgängiges
leuchten von ssd es heißt meistens dass irgendwas mit dem ried nicht funktioniert aber ist der
raspberry pi wirklich im arsch da ist doch wirklich irgendwas kaputt jetzt blinkt er moment jetzt
blinkt er vielleicht alles resizen einfach nur eine weile gedauert jetzt blinkt er nee ich werf
aktuell garantiert kein raspberry pi an die wand weiß wie teuer aktuell und wie schwer zu bekommen
raspberry pi 4 sind nee nee das stimmt schmeiß ich nicht da schmeißt lieber die ssd gegen die
wand die ssd waren die schuld das weiß man nicht er bootet noch er blinkt und leuchtet jetzt durchgängig
alter was ist denn jetzt das problem man auf starten also die ip muss die gleiche sein gleich
der boot nicht so ganz im ernst ah lol alter leute das ist doch nicht normal das ist so
lange brauch selbst beim ersten boot nicht wie heißt die library wo du für den label drucker
gebraucht hast für die labels zu machen gar nichts das haben wir selbst gemacht oder meinst du krupps
erstmal update machen ah die kennen uns leider wie konva konva hieß das konva konva gs es ist
nicht fabric ist es konva hier konva gs das haben wir verwendet
deswegen haben wir auch schon mal gen maar
macht man nun mal weg von base 3
pur trending
Hub
und
dritte
paste
izer
nummer drei
die
gute
beste
lastly
breaks
auf
hat
und
man
slots
нали 10
Chromium. Rosa.
Yes.
Hau drauf. Gib ihm.
Gib ihm. Volle Kerne.
Volle Pulle.
So. Danach
rebooten.
Access Point anmachen.
Und dann prage, Leute, dass es funktioniert.
Wenn es funktioniert, dann erzähle ich euch
meine Theorie, woran es gelegen hat.
Und ihr könnt mir sagen, ob ihr es
für wahrscheinlich haltet.
Oder nicht.
Aber nur, wenn es funktioniert. Weil wenn es nicht funktioniert,
muss ich euch meine Theorie auch nicht erzählen.
Nico, danke für den Sub. Übrigens, wir können
ein bisschen Chat gucken, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Warum habe ich eigentlich Pepo Pupu noch eingeblendet?
Wie gesagt, ich will das Zeug
damit ersetzen.
Hier, da ist OMG, das ist das Programm hier
bei dem Shop, oder? Bei 1400 Euro
Access Point Preisen.
Entweder 64-Bit ist RIP oder
SSD. Nein, ich vermute was anderes. Oder auch.
Aber erzähle ich euch dann, wenn es
funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, mein Handy sagt ja, es funktioniert.
Meine Antenne stört. Ja, das ist es.
Das wird's sein.
Max ist kurz davor.
Englisch, German Kid, genau.
Anhöhl Tournament.
Bettke macht der Raspberry Pi.
Deswegen nehme ich normalerweise
eine SSD, weil es damit dreimal schneller geht.
Als mit der Micro-SD-Karte.
So, wir schalten schon mal den Access Point ein.
Dass der ready ist, sobald ich...
Chat, jetzt wo so viele da sind.
Ich frage euch mal was.
Ich habe aktuell eine ganz billige
Fritzbox für DECT und VoIP.
Das Unity Media
Kabelmodem als Einwahlgerät
und einen MikroTik-Router für Routing.
So weit, so gut.
Und ihr wisst ja, ich habe ziemliche Probleme
mit dem Fernsehempfang drüben,
weil mein Raspberry Pi mit USB-Stick
rumspackt.
Deswegen habe ich einmal zur Auswahl, entweder mir
so ein Ding zu kaufen.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, nur,
als Empfänger.
Im Wohnzimmer bleibt
weiterhin mein
Shield-TV dran.
Das würde ich nur benutzen,
als Empfänger.
Das hat 8 Tuner drin, quasi.
Ein Octa-Tuner, sozusagen.
Und das würde ich benutzen zum
Streamen
an das Kodi auf dem
Shield-TV. Also, was haltet ihr
für sinnvoller? So ein Ding zu kaufen?
Oder ich könnte mir auch
eine Fritzbox-Kabel kaufen.
So was da.
Ich könnte mir auch eine Kabel-Fritzbox
kaufen. Die hat einen Quad-Tuner
drinne und ich könnte damit
quasi das Unity-Media-Modem
und
meine
Billig-Fritzbox
ersetzen und hätte noch gleich
einen Tuner dabei.
Was meint ihr, ihr Sinniger?
Preislich nimmt es sich lustigerweise gar nicht so viel.
Der VU-Plus?
Ganz ehrlich, ich tendiere auch
zum VU-Plus, weil das
Ding wohl echt nice, also
qualitativ echt nice
sein muss, was die Tuner angeht.
Aber wie gesagt, ich möchte
die VU-Plus
nicht benutzen als
Endgerät am Fernseh, nur
als Empfänger und Streamer.
Also, mein Shield-TV
mit Kodi bleibt weiterhin im Wohnzimmer
und ich werde
dann einfach dort das
Kodi-Plugin verwenden
dafür und darüber streamen.
Aber ich meine, die VU-Plus hat
einen Vorteil, es ist ein weiteres Gerät.
Ich bin ja mittlerweile kein Fan
mehr von so Single-Point-of-Failures.
Weil
dazu kommt,
Leute, ich bin dumm, es geht
überhaupt nicht.
Das geht überhaupt nicht. Ich brauche
eine Fritzbox und einen Raspberry Pi mit
TV-Head-End, weil ich will doch aufnehmen
und die Fritzbox aufnehmen
mit TV-Head-End geht ja gar nicht.
Also ich bräuchte quasi die Kombi
Fritzbox plus Raspberry Pi mit TV-Head-End
und SSD dran oder,
quasi eine Box für alles
mit SSD drinnen.
Also, so.
Ist denn jetzt... Okay,
Configure me. Raspberry Config.
System, Wireless LAN.
Deutschland.
Yes.
Konfigure. Punkt. Ich kann es fast auswendig.
Me. Minus.
3, 7, DC, 4, 0.
Yes. Keine Passphrase.
Yes. Yes. Reboot.
Foggers.
Gut.
So, und wenn es jetzt geht,
sage ich euch, woran es gelegen hat.
Ich habe nämlich eine Vermutung,
woran es gelegen hat.
Und dann müsst ihr sagen,
magst du es ergibt Sinn oder nicht?
Oder ihr sagt Weirdchamp.
Ich habe letztens alles auf die Fritzbox umgestellt.
Ja, von so einer Enigma-Box
oder von wo hast du auf die Fritzbox umgestellt?
Und mich würde interessieren,
wenn du von so einer Box umgestellt hast, warum?
Weil, wie gesagt, Fritzbox umstellen alleine
bringt ja nichts. Also man braucht, ähm,
man braucht ja noch einen Raspberry Pi mit TV
halt dann zum Aufnehmen.
Und das muss problemlos funktionieren,
der ganze Krempel, weil das ist für meine Mutter.
Also der Kram, der muss laufen.
Ich habe keinen Bock, dass ich Support geben muss.
Okay.
Hydroleon, ich habe keine Ahnung.
So, Leute.
Wir sind verbunden.
Es hat funktioniert.
Nein.
Cody kann nicht mit der Fritzbox aufnehmen.
Du kannst mit der Fritzbox, du kannst mit Cody
ein IPTV-Addon verwenden,
das kann er aber nicht aufnehmen.
Gescheit.
So, es funktioniert mit dem WLAN.
Alles klar.
ARP-N
So, WIM, ETC, Hosts.
Ah, ARP, Install, WIM.
Woran hat es gelegen, sage ich euch gleich,
sobald ich im Browser drauf bin.
Ich sage euch, woran es gelegen hat.
Dann werdet ihr sagen, Max pfeift,
oder ihr werdet sagen, er gibt keinen Sinn.
Okay, auf.
WIM, ETC, Hosts.
Zack.
Und jetzt, wo muss ich drauf?
Unleashed.com.
Chrome.
Egal, ob ihr da irgendwelche
ALSA-Packages nicht findet, geht einfach auf.
Das war gerade die Windows-Tastatur.
Prokus.
Jawoll.
Bam.
Da sind wir, Leute, wir haben es geschafft.
Okay, ich sage euch, woran es gelegen hat.
Also, ich vermute, das lag an der SSD.
Allerdings nicht, weil die SSD kaputt ist,
sondern ich vermute,
das liegt daran, weil die SSD zu viel Strom gezogen hat.
Ich vermute, die SSD hat zu viel Strom verbraucht.
Und deswegen hat das WLAN rumgespackt.
Weil der Raspberry Pi,
der ist nicht so üppig bemessen,
was Stromverbrauch am USB-Anschluss geht.
Und manche SSDs brauchen halt ordentlich was.
Ich glaube, der Raspberry Pi kann maximal 0,5,
also 500 mA am USB,
oder 1 Ampere mittlerweile am USB.
Und SSDs,
SSDs,
brauchen halt manchmal ein bisschen mehr,
wenn man...
Ich meine, ich habe die SSD da schon lange dran,
keine Ahnung,
aber ich habe nie WLAN in Kombination damit verwendet.
Und wahrscheinlich braucht das Ding zu wenig,
zieht das Ding zu viel Strom,
dass es halt auch instabil wird,
was die SSD angeht.
Ihr habt ja gesehen,
wie die Performance-Dinger von der SSD geschwankt ist.
Okay, Leute, wir sind hier am Start.
Also, wir müssen es jetzt einrichten.
Also, Language,
Englisch,
Name,
Rugos Unleashed,
Country Code.
Ähm,
by the way,
ihr seht, dass ich hier den Country Code auswählen kann.
Das liegt daran, weil ich das mit dem Country Unlock,
das habe ich euch schon gesagt,
schon gemacht habe.
Aber,
wie gesagt, wir machen es trotzdem nochmal zusammen,
dass ihr seht, wie es funktioniert.
Ja, es ist die alte Version drauf.
Ich stelle aber Country Code schon mal auf.
Name ist Cute Chat.
Language,
Englisch, kein Mesh,
Germany, jawohl, IP Settings.
DHCP ist okay.
Kann, kann er behalten.
Kann ich mich von dort dann da drauf verbinden?
Vom Raspberry Pi, wenn ich das dem dann...
Ja, egal.
Primary DNS, alles vom DHCP ziehen.
Na, ich flash da nichts auf 64-bit jetzt.
Gut, äh, next.
Wireless LAN, SSID,
Passwort-Projekt, ja.
Äh, das WLAN heißt Vodafone.
Tarnung ist alles, keck weh.
Moment.
Ah, ich habe mich vertippt.
Bei meinem WLAN-Passwort.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ah, ich kann mein WLAN-Passwort nicht richtig tippen gerade.
The fuck?
Ich habe englisches Tastatur-Layout.
Monka.
Alter, was ist denn das?
Was zum...
Ja, so will ich das haben.
Geht doch.
Okay, das nehmen wir als WLAN-Passwort.
Also, WLAN-Passwort.
Gutes Passwort.
Äh, next.
Administrator-Passwort.
Ja, huge, huge, massive Passwort.
Kommt nie einer drauf.
Äh, next.
Alles klar, finish.
Unleash will restart after you click.
Okay.
Nein, nein, ich klicke yes, nicht okay.
Yes.
So, jetzt muss ich es an meinen Router anstöpseln gleich.
Next point.
Und dann in...
Äh, dann in meinen Router schauen.
Schauen.
Was der für eine IP bekommt.
IP.
DHCP-Server-Leases.
All diese Musik.
So, sollte sich das Ding jetzt neu gestartet haben?
Mal schauen.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Ich glaube, Leute, es hat sich neu gestartet, oder?
Sollte passen.
Gut.
Äh, machen wir das hier dicht.
Aus ist.
Ähm, okay.
Also, der Raspberry Pi.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt auch aus ist, der Access Point.
Ja, ist aus.
Okay.
Ähm, das heißt, der Access Point sollte jetzt, wenn ich den anstelle,
stöpsel, an meinen Switch,
dann sollte der sich eigentlich
jetzt eine interne IP holen
und ich kann mich drauf verbinden.
Soweit die Idee.
Strom raus.
Anschließen.
Und rein.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, was passiert.
So.
Auf booten, please.
Boot, blitz.
Also, sollte irgendeiner,
1, 9, 2, 1, 6, 8, 2,
100,
paar und 20 oder so bekommen wahrscheinlich.
Es hat sich gerade ein Rechner mit dem Namen Six
hat eine neue IP gezogen.
Meine, meine
Hausnamen werden auch nicht gerade kreativer.
So, Poggas hat sich auch wieder eine neue IP gezogen.
Äh, 1, 9, 2, 1, 6, 8, 2.140.
Könnte der das sein?
Moment, mal ausprobieren.
1, 9, 2, 1, 6, 2, 140.
Vielleicht.
Ich hab 2.140 hab ich jetzt zur Auswahl.
Das andere ist mein Desktop.
Also ping 1, 9, 2, 1, 6, 2, 140.
Okay, nmap, mal gucken, was da läuft.
Äh, das sieht schon mal gut aus.
Das könnte durchaus ein Access Point sein.
Oder auch nicht.
Hundertfien...
Nein.
Nee.
Das ist er, glaube ich.
Das müsste der Access Point sein.
Warum auch immer es nicht aufgeht im Browser.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, der Access Point.
SSH.
Was?
Alter, wie alt ist denn das SSH da drauf?
Ach ja, HTTPS.
Ihr habt recht.
Aber eigentlich sollte der auch redirecten, oder?
Nee, macht der automatisch.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass der das ist.
Abyss ist offen.
Alles klar.
Moment, da ist überhaupt nichts offen auf Port 80.
Oder ist er das doch nicht?
Okay, wir können jetzt einfach testen, ob er das ist, Leute.
Wir pingen den.
Und ich ziehe jetzt den Stecker raus.
Wobei, anhand der MAC sollte ich es doch eigentlich auch erkennen.
2.140.
MAC-Address.
Was ist das?
MAC.
Ruckus.
Jawoll.
Das muss er wohl sein, oder?
Ah, jetzt.
Der braucht einfach nur 3 Stunden zum Booten, Alter.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Alles klar.
Upp.
Nein.
Nicht wirklich, Firefox.
Nicht wirklich.
Gut versucht, aber nein.
Admin.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 wahrscheinlich, wenn ich mich so kenne.
Yo.
So.
Wifi-Networks.
Da sind wir doch.
Nein.
Skip.
Ich register nichts.
Wifi-Networks.
Vodafone.
Disabled.
Ich will kein Network anhaben.
So.
Und jetzt müssen wir uns eine Root-Shell besorgen, um Country-Code zu unlocken.
Also.
SSH.
Boah.
Minus O.
Key.
Was ich denn aus dem Kopf, wie man das angibt?
SSH-Option.
Key-Types oder irgendwie sowas.
Äh.
Nein.
Da brauche ich irgendeine SSH-Option.
Das Ding ist so alt, das unterstützt die neuesten SSH-Keys gar nicht mehr.
Hier.
Host-Key-Algorithm ist es.
Host-Key-Algorithm.
SSH-RSA.
POG.
Funktioniert.
Minus R.
Löschen.
So.
Yes.
Admin.
Da sind wir.
CLI-Interface.
PRAGE hat geholfen.
So.
Und jetzt müssen wir den Country-Unlock machen.
Nämlich das da.
Also.
Deswegen haben wir nämlich downgraded.
By the way.
Das.
Also wir haben die Firmware downgraded, dass die Firmware noch eine Sicherheitslücke
hat, dass ich eine Root-Shell bekomme.
Also.
Enable.
Debug.
So.
You have all rights in this mode.
Script.
Exeg.
Das so was.
Also dass die sowas übersehen, ist ja eigentlich schon fragwürdig, oder?
Kann man nach dem Change wieder upgraden?
Jawü.
Exeg.
Ähm.
Das da.
Exit.
So.
Und jetzt haben wir Root-Rechte.
Wir haben Root-Rechte!
Wir haben komplett Root-Rechte!
und und kommandozeilen zugang jetzt sowas da kommandozeilen zugang auf unseren access point
so knecht rudrecht das habe ich ja nicht gehört und was soll das bringen jetzt kann man den
country code umstellen von us auf weltweit remove country lock jetzt muss man nämlich sagen bsp set
fix country code 0 und dann muss man sagen bsp commit und jetzt hat man den country code
unlockt und ich kann von us auf germany umstellen und jetzt reboot jetzt haben wir country unlockt
jetzt darf ich den nämlich auch in deutschland betreiben was ich offiziell eigentlich hätte
vorher nicht machen dürfen
auch ganz schön lang zum rebooten ich wollte kurz was zu trinken holen ich bin back so gut also da
sollte jetzt rebooten und dann machen wir ein firmware upgrade das können wir übrigens schon
mal da ist er wieder der braucht eine halbe stunde bis er hochgefahren ist jetzt können wir schon mal
die neueste firmware herunterladen nämlich da da da da die da was hat irgendjemand plan was uns
das heißen soll mrga
wurde drinnen
ms cross Notice
mtr ist es aus wie осma
oberرج
coisa
und g th
charity
brems
or
oder
so was
und beobachten
die
killing
dana
sad
was
수
who
persecution
a
fair
oft
cake
Der hat zumindest der Chat wieder, Alter.
Einfach irgendwas hingeschrieben, Mann.
Magic Resistance.
Ja, das bestimmt.
PP-Chat, Alter.
Merch-Request.
Stellsohr, danke für den Sub.
27 Monate.
Okay, wir laden das aber schon mal runter.
Das scheint ja das Aktuellste zu sein,
was es gibt.
Weil, ne.
Okay, mein Download
funktioniert noch.
Moment, den Download muss ich auf den...
Ach ne, den kann ich jetzt ja von hier machen.
So, sind wir wieder am Start?
Wir sind wieder da.
SSH.
Admin.
Was auch immer.
Okay, also ist alles wieder da.
Funktioniert. Exit.
Oder Quit.
Ich hab Exit gesagt und schreib Quit.
Und das funktioniert dann lustigerweise auch,
obwohl ich nicht Exit...
Gut, also.
Dann können wir jetzt ja wieder upgraden.
Damit, übrigens,
wenn wir upgraden,
damit schließen wir uns auch
die Root-Shell, ja.
Ach, Moment. GA ist quasi ein
Major-Release und was ist dann
MR? Minor-Release wahrscheinlich.
Das ist ja die beknackteste
Bezeichnung, die ich je gehört hab dafür.
So.
Wenn wir upgraden auf die neueste Firmware,
dann haben wir keine Root-Shell mehr
auf dem Access-Point.
Weil das ein Bug war, der gefixt wurde.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen,
es gibt Schlimmeres.
Ich brauche nicht unbedingt eine Root-Shell auf dem Access-Point,
solange der, ähm,
das Management und so alles in Ordnung ist.
Okay.
Country-Code.
Germany. Sehr schön.
Also. Administration.
Upgrade.
Checking for Updates.
Wie? Kann er...
Kann er jetzt online etwa upgraden?
Alter, ich muss die Firma nicht mehr hochladen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Weil ich kann direkt über das Webinterface...
Upgrade.
Ist das auch das Richtige?
Äh... 1, 2, 7?
1, 2, 7. Jawoll!
Upgrade.
POG.
Gib ihm.
Master Progress.
Ja, ja, mach.
Warning!
Die Zukunft ist hier. Ja.
Und das ist von 2020, der Access-Point.
Also die Neuen sind wahrscheinlich noch besser.
Ne, 2019 ist der.
Glaub ich, der Access...
Ne, noch älter.
Wenn es Releases von 2018 gab.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man in Deutschland...
...US-WLAN nutzt?
Wird die Polizei bei einem anklopfen?
Wahrscheinlich wird dir gar nichts passieren.
Weil es keiner richtig merkt.
Aber ganz streng genommen ist es nicht korrekt.
Weil die unterschiedliche...
...Reglements da haben.
Was Sendeleistung angeht.
Channels angeht, die erlaubt sind und sowas.
Wahrscheinlich wird es keiner merken.
Es ist ja nicht so, als würde es so großartig was stören.
Und das deswegen auffällt.
Und dann irgendjemand nachmisst.
Oder was auch immer.
Wahrscheinlich wird überhaupt nichts passieren.
Aber...
Aber man muss es ja nicht...
...machen, weil...
...das hat ja durchaus seinen Sinn.
Dass es diese Vorgaben gibt.
Ja, wenn jeder quasi mit...
...auf der Frequenz...
...und mit der Leistung funken will.
Dir ja lustig ist, funkt irgendwann gar keiner mehr.
Ne, ne.
Das mit den Ländercodes, das funktioniert.
Das war schon deutsch und ausgewählt jetzt.
Das macht gar keine Polizei.
Das macht irgendeine...
...das macht irgendeine andere Prüfstelle...
...würde das machen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es...
...eine Hausdurchsuchung gibt wegen...
...falscher WLAN-Frequenz in Deutschland.
Aber trotzdem, wie gesagt...
...das hat ja seinen Sinn, dass es solche Vorgaben gibt.
In dem Fall ist es tatsächlich...
...zum Besseren von allen.
Weil, wie gesagt...
...wenn jeder funkt, wie er will...
...funkt mal gar keiner mehr.
Okay, er ist anscheinend wieder da.
Einfach mal refreshen.
Okay, exit...
...neu gestartet ist er noch nicht.
Endmap.
Aha.
Die Webinterface-Ports sind noch nicht oben.
Webinterface, starte dich.
Sehe ich das richtig, da ist Telnet offen?
Ach nee, Moment.
FDP?
Warum genau hat der...
...Port 21 auf?
Warum ist...
...wo kommt man da raus, wenn man da drauf geht?
FDP?
Warum ist da ein...
...FDP drauf?
Administration System Settings.
Ja, da gucken wir jetzt auch gleich mal.
Admin?
References?
Nee. System?
Kann man das hier vielleicht gar nicht einstellen?
Services? FDP?
Hm, wo könnte man sowas wie ein...
...FDP sauber einstellen? Administration?
Network Connectivity?
Network Management?
Hm.
It's a Trap.
Mobile App?
Äh...
Kann man das ausschalten?
FDP Settings?
System?
System Settings?
Nö.
SMS? E-Mail?
Also FDP darf man anscheinend nicht ausschalten, okay?
Nice.
Management Interface?
Reddit?
Unleashed? Disable FDP?
Warum ist da ein FDP-Server auf?
Welchen Telnet-Client hast du verwendet?
Ich weiß nicht, ob da Linux dabei ist.
Oder, das Telnet, was Telnet heißt,
habe ich verwendet.
Okay, ist jetzt auch nicht so wild.
So.
Aber, immerhin, es funktioniert schon mal.
Also, wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben?
Update auf den neuesten Stand?
Setup?
Wifi einrichten? Haben wir ja im Prinzip schon gemacht.
Wim Raspberry Pi testen?
Okay, dann testen wir doch jetzt mal eines der Features,
warum ich diese Dinger nice finde.
Services?
Äh, Authentification?
Services? Access Control vielleicht?
Alter, was kannst
du da alles einstellen, Mann?
Äh, okay.
Device Access?
Client Isolation
Whitelist?
Application Recognition
und Control?
Was zum Teufel?
Das will ich alles gar nicht machen.
Bonjour Gateway?
Ist Bonjour nicht irgend so ein Apple-Ding?
Dynamic PSK?
Ja, das ist das, was ich gleich ausprobieren will.
Guest Access Service?
Hotspot?
Self-Healing?
Na, da bin ich ja immer
sehr skeptisch.
WIPS?
Gut, das auch immer. Keine Ahnung.
Gucken wir uns mal die WLAN-Settings an.
Also, Vodafone WLAN.
Das ist das krasseste Cheap-Name
von einem WLAN überhaupt jetzt, oder?
Dass es einfach Vodafone heißt
und mit Vodafone nichts zu tun hat.
So, Settings für das WLAN.
Passwort?
Nein, das Passwort will ich euch nicht
schauen.
Advanced Settings?
Genau, hier kann man PSK einstellen.
So, External?
Da kann man irgendeinen Radioserver hinterlegen,
was ich nicht vorhabe.
Internal?
Zero-IT will ich nicht haben.
Zero-IT ist bei denen so was,
es gibt ein offenes WLAN,
da kannst du dich anmelden
und dort kriegst du dann quasi
also, neuer Mitarbeiter meldet sich an,
dort loggst du dich dann einmalig ein
und dort kriegst du dann die Zertifikate
für das eigentliche WLAN.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Also, Dynamic PSK will ich haben.
Damit kann man von der Idee her
für jedes Endgerät
ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort generieren.
Das probieren wir mit dem Raspberry Pi
gleich aus.
So, weil wir gerade beim Raspberry Pi sind,
machen wir SSH, gehen wir da nochmal drauf.
Pi-Add
sudo-i, nicht sudo,
sudo-i,
etc,
wpa,
ich lösche die WLAN-Settings mal
und reboote, weil
das WLAN gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Okay, Keylänge,
ganz ehrlich,
auf 62 Sachen habe ich wirklich keinen Bock.
Nehmen wir mal,
nehmen wir mal,
keine Ahnung,
20 oder so,
oder
okay,
24.
24 sollte noch reichen als
WLAN-Passwort.
Oder komm, wir sind Informatikors, 32.
So,
expire, okay,
das ist, wenn man irgendeinem Typ
ein Passwort gibt, was weiß ich, man hat Besuch,
man hat Besuch
und möchte, dass der eine,
dass der das bekommt.
Okay, na das ist ja schwachsinnig,
das brauche ich nicht.
Raspberry Pi soll unlimited Zugang
haben.
One per device,
ja, klingt doch sinnvoll.
Eins pro Gerät, sollte doch,
sollte doch reichen.
Das hier ist, glaube ich, nur sinnvoll,
in Kombination mit Zero-IT, dass man sich
beispielsweise ein Gerät, ein User
für seine drei Smartphones
Keys generieren kann, aber das wollen wir ja gar nicht.
Okay, WLAN-Priority,
Hi,
Hide SSID, MonkaS,
Access WLAN.
Ich meine, das könnte man jetzt einstellen,
wenn man WLAN-Support gerade da an dem Switch
irgendwie eingeschaltet, aber
warum nicht?
Okay, was kann man sonst noch machen?
Access Control.
What?
Ah, man kann sagen, wie viel
Bandbreite jeder Client
maximal verwenden darf, das ist ganz praktisch,
wenn viel los ist.
Enable per SSID
Uplink, Downlink.
Das kann man auch per
SSID machen, okay, also sprich,
wenn man irgendeine Kamera-WLAN hat oder irgendwie
was, dann kann man, das ist nice.
Access Control, ja, wir wollen es jetzt mal nicht
übertreiben.
Mac Access, Layer 3
und 4 Access,
Device Policies, das will ich alles
gar nicht machen.
Radio Control.
Was ist 802.11r
FT Roaming?
802.11
RT Roaming.
1111r
Ah, das ist ja nur mehr,
das ist das, was normalerweise unter
Fast Roaming oder was auch immer,
ja, das ist ja nur mehr, dass
der Client das, besser gesagt, dass
die Access Points
zu den Handoff miteinander koordinieren.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich nice, aber gut,
brauche ich nicht, ich habe ja aktuell nur einen Access Point dran.
Ähm,
Background Scanning, Load Balancing,
OSAS,
Force DHCP,
Isolate Wireless from other Clients,
das will ich haben, für ein IoT-Netzwerk,
auf jeden Fall.
Isolate Wireless Client
Traffic from all Hosts
on the same WLAN Subnet.
Ähm,
ne, same
AP reicht. Mal gucken.
Okay.
Ich meine, das WLAN ist eh immer noch
aus. Wie stehst du
eigentlich zu OpenWrt und PFSense? Das ist mega
nice, gerade OpenWrt ist richtig pock
an Features. Leider haben sie
das mit diesem dynamischen
Key noch nicht fertig eingebaut
und PFSense hatte ich auch noch eine Weile.
War mir aber alles ein wenig zu
Single Point of Failure, was ich gebaut habe,
mit meiner fetten Kiste.
Also ich hatte OpenSense, ich hatte, stimmt,
ich hatte kein PFSense, ich hatte OpenSense.
So, und wie generiere
ich jetzt Passwörter für meine Clients?
Close?
Ähm,
Show Client Info, ja, gibt nix, ne?
Show Client Info.
Show System
Overview.
Ach ja, das Ding hat übrigens zwei Interfaces.
Falls man das braucht.
Ähm, wo lege ich denn jetzt?
Ah, hier lege ich jetzt Keys an.
Target WLAN Vodafone
Number to create.
Generated Dynamic PSKs.
Okay, hier kann ich jetzt Passwörter
generieren
für einzelne Clients.
Okay, was
passiert, wenn ich jetzt auf Generate klicke?
Ich mein, das WLAN ist aus, ich werd jetzt hier nix leaken.
512,
ja, damit sollte ich auskommen.
Generate
Dynamic PSKs.
Äh, okay.
Und wo sehe ich jetzt das Passwort?
To download latest, klick hier.
Seriously?
Als CSV?
Ernsthaft?
Meine WLAN Passwörter als
CSV.
Na geil, Mann.
Stehen da jetzt die Passwörter im Klartext drinne?
Ich bin mir gar nicht so
sicher, ob ich das jetzt aufmachen soll.
Egal, ich mach das jetzt
auf.
Das WLAN ist eh
Discard, yes.
Ah, geh weg.
Das WLAN ist eh offen.
Äh, nicht offen, ist eh disabled.
Ach, hier ist das Passwort jetzt
im Klartext drinne, okay.
Aber ohne MAC-Adress, also ohne MAC-Adress
heißt das, kann jeder einmalig verwenden, oder
wie ist das? Hm, keine Ahnung.
Das wären jetzt
die WLAN Passwörter für 5 unterschiedliche Geräte.
Okay.
So, das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier
sagen, delete all, zack,
und alle wieder rufen, Gerät wegschmeißen
und keiner mehr Zugriff.
So, jetzt muss ich
mir da irgendwie mal ein Passwort rauskopieren.
Ohne,
dass ihr das seht.
Testen wir das doch mal.
Also, numbers to create one.
Ah, Moment, kann ich irgendwie auch die Dinger von Hand
vergeben?
DPSK-Batch,
to download, ich kann nämlich, ich kann
nämlich fertige Profile,
uploaden,
example profile,
aha.
Hier könnte ich jetzt MAC-Adressen von Anfang an
hinterlegen. Also, da könnte ich zum Beispiel sagen,
keine Ahnung, das ist Gast,
äh, Max,
oder so, wenn der Typ so heißt.
Und da könnte ich mir dafür was anlegen,
das, okay, das brauche ich jetzt nicht.
Aber wir probieren es trotzdem mal aus. Keine Ahnung, es gibt jetzt
Gast, Gast Max und, äh,
Raspberry Pi.
Keine Ahnung. Raspberry Pi
Keller.
Oh, da wisst man sogar, wie das Ding heißt.
So, save,
zu TSV,
leer,
okay, der würde jetzt einen neuen User anlegen.
So, das würde jetzt drei User anlegen,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Also, upload,
generate, das funktioniert.
Das ist, das ist nice.
Was natürlich
cool wäre, wenn ich den PSK mir selbst
ausdenken kann, aber ich glaube nicht, dass
das funktioniert. Was eigentlich gar nicht
so schlimm ist, weil so hat man auf jeden Fall sichere
Passwörter. Okay, das waren jetzt
die Passwörter für den Access Point.
Okay,
das ist tatsächlich ganz
nice. Das muss man
auf jeden Fall so machen,
weil, checkt
doch am Ende keiner mehr, wer hier was ist,
wenn die einfach dynamic generated heißen.
Wobei man es anhand der Mac
hier dann zuordnen könnte.
So, jetzt müssen wir es
irgendwie ausprobieren. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt
in WLAN, ich muss jetzt ein Passwort generieren, ohne
dass ihr das seht.
Chat.
Ihr müsst jetzt mal kurz,
generate, ihr müsst jetzt mal kurz ausgeblendet
werden. Also gibt es
eine Mac-Adress-Whitelist. Ne, du kannst es nach
Mac-Adresse machen oder dynamisch. Ich probiere
es jetzt mal dynamisch.
So, Display Capture aus.
Chat, ihr müsst jetzt mal kurz, kurz weg.
EPSK,
okay.
Alles klar, ich habe mir eins rauskopiert.
Und wieder zu.
Geht nicht alles.
Und wieder da.
So,
also jetzt habe ich das Passwort mir rauskopiert
von Raspberry Pi, was der jetzt gleich kriegt.
Und dann
sagen wir doch jetzt mal, also wir haben jetzt
hier, EPSK,
generate, alles mit Mac
0, Passwort sieht man jetzt hier nicht mehr.
Also man hat einmalig die Chance, das Passwort
zu sehen, sonst sieht man das Passwort nie wieder.
Was eigentlich ganz gut ist, so.
So, ähm,
jetzt machen wir das WLAN an.
Enable.
Jetzt gehen wir auf den Raspberry Pi.
Und sagen,
die Namen kannst du
editieren, ja. Achso, ne,
später editieren geht glaube ich
nicht. Du kannst sie
beim Anlegen editieren.
Ja, das ist, das ist nicht so schön.
Vielleicht ist es in der neueren Version besser.
Wisst ihr, das ist auch was, wo ich mir
durchaus vorstellen kann, ein Kommandozeilen-Tool
zu basteln, was das
für einen macht. Das können wir gleich noch
probieren. Da müssen wir irgendwie
Chrome fernsteuern oder so. Das wird lustig.
Also, Raspberry Pi.
System.
Wireless LAN.
SSID. Vodafone.
Und Passwort.
Copy, Paste. Bam.
Finish.
Bam! Aha!
Und jetzt ist es
dynamisch gebunden auf die IP
vom Raspberry Pi, also sprich auf die
MAC-Adresse. Also sprich, die erste
MAC, also das erste Gerät,
was sich verbindet
mit diesem Passwort,
ähm,
dann ist das wohl gelockt. Also
sprich,
jetzt könnte ich es wieder löschen.
Anhand, anhand der MAC.
Das finde ich cool. Das ist, das ist sehr nice.
Das ist wirklich
cool. Das gefällt mir echt.
So, und wenn ich jetzt, das probieren wir auch mal aus,
ob das funktioniert. Sekunde.
Ähm,
was hat das Ding für ne, für ne gekriegt?
So, ich muss mich, muss grad mal pingen.
Ha?
Das ist der Raspberry Pi.
Nutzen das nicht Hotels? Doch, auch.
So, und jetzt sagen wir ihm hier mal,
ähm, delete.
Und jetzt sollte ja der Ping ausgehen gleich.
Hoffe ich mal.
Aber disable gibt's
nicht, ne? Es gibt nur delete.
Disable gibt's nicht. Na gut.
Es kommt kein anderer mit dem Passwort
mehr rein und wenn ich es lösche, noch nicht mal er selbst.
Das heißt, ich könnte das Gerät jetzt wegschmeißen.
Zack!
Ich hab's ja nur die MAC-Adresse spooft, bringt dir das
ja nix.
Weil, das Passwort
gibt, gilt jetzt nicht mehr.
Also du musst das Passwort kennen
und die MAC-Adresse
spoofen und ich muss
es noch nicht gelöscht haben.
Die Sache ist bloß die, du hast keine Chance, das Passwort
rauszubekommen, wenn du nicht mal ein Gerät zufällig im Müll
findest.
Also eigentlich ist das ziemlich gut durchdacht.
Guck, es funktioniert.
Nice. Sehr, sehr nice.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Das ist genau das, was man haben will
für IoT-Geräte.
Genau das.
Clients connected.
Guck hier, da steht er drin.
Status unauthorized.
Hier kann man's...
Also ganz ehrlich, das finde ich von...
Obwohl das erst noch von vor 1,5 Jahren ist,
hier das Update, was ich bekomme, finde ich das
vom Handling her schon um Längen besser als
dem Unify-Controller.
Wenn du jetzt neue generierst, werden die
dazu addiert zu der existierenden Liste
oder stellen... Ne, ne, die werden hinzugefügt.
Die werden hinzugefügt, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Können wir mal ausprobieren.
EPSK
Keine Ahnung, Numbers to create 2
Generate
Bam, zwei Stück generiert.
Generate 2
4, ja.
Der addet die neu.
Ja.
Ja, anders wäre das ja auch komplett
komplett useless, Alter.
Jetzt wäre es natürlich noch cool,
wenn ich irgendwie
also es wäre zwei Sachen cool,
wenn ich das nicht über eine
CSV-Datei machen müsste,
wenn man das irgendwie
mit irgendeinem Kommandozeilentool dafür bauen könnte.
Gibt es Github Unleashed
API, gibt es da sowas schon?
Pi Ruckus
Python Client for Ruckus
Unleashed, das ist doch gut.
Es ist halt sehr
nichtssagend.
Kannst du eine bestehende Liste von Namen her bearbeiten?
Nein.
Du kannst importieren
mit den Namen, die du haben willst,
aber du kannst nachträglich nichts mehr daran ändern.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es
daran liegt, wie er den Key errechnet.
Oder weil sie noch keinen Bock hatten, das zu implementieren.
Da wäre jetzt natürlich eine Rootshell
auf dem Gerät äußerst nice,
weil dann könnte ich gucken, in welcher Textdatei
das drinsteht und das von Hand einfügen.
Aber gut.
Kann er ja alles haben.
Also diese API erschließt
sich mir mal überhaupt gar nicht.
Generate, exportieren, bearbeiten,
importieren.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Du kannst.
Wobei.
Vielleicht.
Okay.
Wir generaten mal
vier Stück.
Generate, so.
Download.
Ja gut, das würde, ne.
Das sind ganz andere Felder.
Ich meine, ich kann es mal ausprobieren.
Keg, Keg W1.
Wir legen jetzt Keg W1 bis 4 an.
Passphrase
123, 12345.
12345.
Das sollte so nicht funktionieren.
WLAN Vodafone, MAC-Adress.
Ne, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Okay, Upload. Error.
Passphrase.
It's not correct. Okay, das mag er nicht.
Ne, kannst du nicht.
Bringt dir nix.
Das kannst du mit in ihrem Controller machen.
Aber ich will ja keinen Controller haben.
Lass mal Original Pw.
Okay.
Okay, machen wir.
Delete.
Generate.
Aber das Original Passwort sollte er ja überhaupt nicht kennen.
So.
Nur die Namen.
Ey, das wird nicht klappen.
Sehr wunder wenn das funktioniert.
Upload.
Nope.
Geht nicht.
Also du kannst nur
Generaten oder Uploaden.
Oder man macht sich wirklich irgendein Kommandozeilentool,
was es für einen anlegt.
Es wäre schon cool, wenn man selbst PSKs
vergeben könnte. Auf der anderen
Seite, ganz im Ernst, ist es gar nicht
so schlecht, dass man es nicht kann.
Dann sind die Dinger wenigstens halbwegs sicher
an Passwörtern und man kommt
gar nicht in Versuchung 123456
oder so einen Blödsinn zu vergeben.
Dass man hier den Namen nicht editieren kann, ist tatsächlich
doof. Aber wisst ihr was?
Die Version ist auch alt.
Vielleicht geht es ja mittlerweile.
Kann ja sein. Aber man bekommt
es ja hier anhand der MAC.
Also nachdem die MAC-Adresse dann
gelockt wird, geht es auch nicht in
einer neuen Version.
Da kann man es anhand der MAC-Adresse dann schon
erkennen, wer was ist.
Es reicht. Also ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Das passt schon.
So, was passiert denn
hier im Hintergrund, Leute?
Das muss ich mal kurz...
Mal kurz im Hintergrund
checken, ob man das einfach
verskripten kann in der Kommandozeile
oder mit einem ferngesteuerten Browser.
Alter, was passiert denn hier im Hintergrund,
Mann? Was passiert
denn hier auf einem Klick bei
Generate? Was passiert
auf einem Klick bei Generate?
Wow!
Alter!
Da macht der 50 Sachen,
Mann!
Embed this.
Ach, das gibt es tatsächlich.
Github. Das ist ein Web-Server oder
wie?
Embed this Web-Apps Samples.
I!
Ein 10++ Web-Server.
Monk AS.
Decrypt X.
Alles klar. Da weißt du ja Bescheid.
Äh...
Generate. Okay, da macht
nur diese zwei Sachen.
docmdcomp?
Okay, das ist ziemlich lichtsagend,
was hier passiert gerade.
Weil ich habe mir gedacht, vielleicht
kann man sich dafür ein kleines Kommandozeilen-Tool
basteln. Sei es, dass es im Hintergrund im Browser
fernsteuert, dass man
nicht Excel-Files,
CSVs hoch und runter
laden muss. Weil das ist schon abfuck, oder?
Download.
Klick hier.
Ja, dann lädt er den Kram runter. Okay.
Save batch
PSK
Filename 0
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Ha!
Das müssen wir jetzt mal testen.
Also, das merke ich mir mal.
Copy, copy url.
So, wenn ich jetzt
nochmal neu generate,
das macht man nur einmal.
Für jedes Gerät
macht man das einmal.
Wenn ich jetzt einen neuen generate,
dann ist ja die
Download-Url anders.
Wenn ich einen neuen generate, ist die
Download-Url ja
so 26.
Gilt denn die alte noch?
Haha!
Die alte gilt auch noch!
She baited!
PSK User 4
Das ist History.
Es ist immer die letzte
Datei.
Egal welche Adresse ich eingebe.
Okay, das haben sie schon mal halbwegs sicher gemacht.
Na, was auch immer.
Ja, vielleicht kann man das irgendwie so einstellen, dass man das ordentlich mit dem Browser
fernsteuern kann.
Das guck ich mir einfach mal off-stream an.
Da hab ich jetzt keine
keinen Nerv mehr für.
Ja, man könnte theoretisch aufzeichnen,
was passiert und es dann
replayen in irgendeinem Puppeteer
Chromium oder sonst was.
Das müsste man tatsächlich mal
ausprobieren. Und sei es
nur, sei es nur, dass man
einfach irgendwelche
Browserklicks simuliert.
Du kannst doch 512 generieren
und daraus immer deinen Schlüssel für ein neues
Gerät nehmen. Ja, das stimmt schon.
Die Sache ist bloß die,
ähm, wenn du mal
Geräte wegschmeißt, dann möchte
du vielleicht neue Schlüssel einfügen und
vielleicht willst du die Dinger ja benennen.
Aktuell heißen die Dinger
BatchDPSCarUser.
Vielleicht will ich denen ja einen gescheiten Namen
geben. Und das muss ich dann bei jedem
Gerät einzeln machen.
Mit dem Upload von so einer CSV-Datei.
Das müsste ich mir mal angucken,
wie man da den Browser fernsteuern kann.
Das ist jetzt nix, was man irgendwie
akut machen muss.
Nein, das ist kein Voucher-System im Sinne,
wie man es kennt. Bei den normalen
Vouchers geht es ja darum,
du gehst in ein offenes WLAN,
ähm, du sagst, ich will 30 Sekunden
joinen und dann kriegst du irgendeinen Code.
Diesen Code benutzt du aber nicht als
WLAN-Passwort, sondern diesen Code gibst
du, nachdem du dich im WLAN eingeloggt hast,
dann nochmal bei irgendeiner Portal-Seite ein.
Das funktioniert ein bisschen anders.
Das ist dann mit, äh,
Captive Portal und Gedöns dabei.
Das ist wirklich auf
WLAN-Ebene.
Genau, man muss das in der CSV-Liste
anpassen und hochladen.
Das geht, das geht, genau.
Das funktioniert.
Du musst immer die CSV-Liste anpassen,
einmalig, wenn du ein neues Gerät hinzufügst,
indem du einen Namen geben willst.
Ja, das geht, das kannst du machen.
Aber das ist trotzdem
sehr nice. Ich überleg mir mal was.
Dann mach ich mir irgendwie so ein CLI,
dass das, ähm,
einfach, ne, dann mach ich
irgendwie so ein CLI, keine Ahnung,
nennen wir das irgendwie kegw.sh
und dann kann ich dann angeben,
keine Ahnung, name,
Raspberry Pi
und eventuell noch Mac.
Aber Mac kann man standardmäßig mehr
leer lassen und dann krieg ich als Antwort das
Passwort.
Nein, nur ein CSV mit 2 und morgen mit 3.
Ja, ja, das geht. Das kannst du machen.
Kannst du machen.
Ich will ja CSV gar nicht editieren.
Ja, man könnte sich mit dem Tool dann auch offline
die Passwörter ablegen, aber ich bin mir gar
nicht so sicher, ob man die Passwörter wirklich, äh,
eigentlich offline dann überhaupt
ablegen möchte, weil
wenn man das Passwort verliert und das Gerät
aus dem WLAN nimmt, dann generiert man sich ein neues Passwort.
Das muss ich
mir überlegen. Keine Ahnung.
Überlegen, muss ich mir überlegen, wie ich das mache.
Weil hier, du hast keine
Chance, das Passwort wieder jemals raus zu
bekommen.
Was auch gut so ist.
Weil die richtigen High IQ
Leute würden das wahrscheinlich über irgendeinen Radioserver
machen oder so, hab ich schon gesehen.
Man kann auch zur Authentifizierung irgendeinen Radioserver
nehmen und darüber die PSKs ziehen,
das hab ich bei denen auf der Webseite gelesen,
das ist mir aber eindeutig
zu overkill. Damit könnte ich
dann aber auch Custom Keys machen.
Aber da hab ich keinen Bock raus zu bekommen, wie das
funktioniert.
So Leute, schwere
Geburt, dank dem
Raspberry Pi, der keinen Bock hatte,
ein Crossbreeder.
DPSK Unleashed Script.
Gibt's da vielleicht schon was?
GitHub.
Was hast du in der Guest Access
für Optionen? Ich hab jetzt den Access Point schon
ausgeschaltet.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Soll ich nochmal einschalten?
Ich schalte nochmal ein, können wir mal gucken.
Ich schalte nochmal ein. Geht doch schnell.
Unleashed.
Ping.
Gucken wir mal, wann er wieder
da ist.
In OpenSense geht sowas
glaube ich,
in OpenSense
kannst du ein Webportal
machen, was sich temporär
einschaltet. Ja, aber sowas wie hier mit den
Custom Passwörtern geht in
OpenSense nicht.
Und wenn doch, würde mich sehr interessieren,
wie das dort heißt und wie das geht.
Guck mal.
GitHub. OpenSense.
Senden sie.
Wollen wir dann sowas gucken. DPSK.
Topics.
DPSK.
Hä?
Äh.
Achso, das ist komplett
äh, ja, ja.
MPSK.
IPS. Das hat da wohl bei OpenSense noch
nie einer zur Sprache gebracht,
dieses Thema.
DPSK.
Nö.
Gibt's nicht.
Vielleicht kannst du das kombinieren mit separaten Netzen
für die Gäste benutzen.
Ja, du kannst, du kannst
denen irgendwie WLANs zuordnen beim Login
dann, das geht.
Hat er sich jetzt
eine neue IP geholt oder was?
Sekunde, ich muss mal in mein DHCP gucken.
Hä?
Der hat die IP immer noch.
Der ist bloß noch nicht gebootet. Der ist nicht so schnell im Booten.
Na gut, Strom war ja auch
komplett weg.
Hostname ist by the way QChat für den
Access Point.
Alter, was bootet der denn in 3 Stunden, Mann?
Anzeige.
Wieder. So. Nö.
So.
Pricked, Leute. Pricked.
Ah, ich weiß, warum es nicht geht.
Ich hab den Switch schon ausgeschaltet.
Lull.
Der Switch, woran er dranhängt, ist aus.
Hier, ich lecke critical information.
Was ist mein Access Point?
Das ist...
ein... der da.
Das hab ich zum rumbasteln gekauft.
Ich hab für daheim
einen R710
zum benutzen.
Okay, Access Point geht nochmal an.
Wie machen die das mit Hotels?
Ja, also entweder mit
sowas hier in der Richtung, oder
was ich ja öfters in Hotels gesehen hab, ist, dass du halt
ein Portal hast, wo du dich anmelden musst.
Und dann temporär
freigeschaltet wird. Weißt du, du gehst in ein offenes
WLAN, oder vielleicht auch in
eins, wo du die Zugangsdaten
bekommst unten, musst dich aber nochmal explizit
in ein Portal freischalten.
Was ich mache? Jetzt nichts mehr.
Wir sind eigentlich mehr oder weniger fertig.
Ich wollte jetzt bloß nochmal für den
Basti nachgucken,
was unter Guest Access steht, wenn
der Access Point mal irgendwann gestartet ist.
Da ist er.
Nmap.
Jetzt braucht er eine Weile, bis der hochgefahren ist.
Was können die besser als Unify?
Boah, hab ich mich heute am Anfang im Stream drüber ausgelassen.
Zum Beispiel können die
eigene Passwörter pro Gerät
für das gleiche WLAN.
Da hat Unify nämlich kein
Bock drauf, sowas zu implementieren.
Darf ich deinen Router mal
testen?
Hä? Wie jetzt?
Per VPN, oder wie?
Nee. So, ist das jetzt so?
Okay.
Weiß gucken wir gleich.
Alter, eben war das
Webinterface da auf.
Warum ist das Webinterface jetzt wieder zu?
Die können sich nicht entscheiden.
Webinterface ist noch nicht auf. Okay, ist noch nicht gestartet
das Ding.
Ich hör mal kurz hier das an.
Das ist WPA Enterprise, das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes.
Nee, das ist
was anderes.
Guck, du kannst hier auch nur
ein Passwort angeben.
WPA Key Management Mode
würde mich tatsächlich mal
interessieren.
Was dahinter steckt.
WPA
Key Management
Mode.
WPA Key Management Mode.
Steht dahinter.
Was?
Alter, da weißt du überhaupt nicht, was die, was
das ist ja wieder. Er wird nichts sagen.
Okay, ist es jetzt offen? Jo.
Alles klar.
Okay, also. Äh, Basti, was
soll ich gucken? Services,
Guest, Access.
Das da? Ah, da kannst du wahrscheinlich
Ah, da kannst du solche Pässe
generieren. Wenn du ein offenes
WLAN hast und möchtest, dass man dann irgendwie so ein
Tal hat. Ja.
Da kannst du Guest Access generieren.
Irgendwelche,
irgendwelche, ähm,
Tokens
für die.
Das ist ja quasi das Klassische. Das ist aber dann nicht
WLAN-Passwörter unterschiedlich pro Gerät.
Printout.
In French!
Hauptsache, das
gibt's in Französisch, Alter.
Mhm, mhm, mhm. Alles klar.
Okay, Guest WLAN.
So, so? Nee.
Nee.
Oh!
Reicht. Fast vier Stunden on gewesen.
Hat ewig gedauert, weil
Kram am Raspberry Pi nicht funktioniert hat.
Ah, ja.
Geht's auf.
Wir sehen uns. Bis im nächsten Stream.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen. Bis denn.
See you.